Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass, die 2. Männer-Bundesliga, eine weiter unglaublich knappe Liga, das Topspiel direkt vor der Nase. Zwei Trainer-Entlassungen auch noch mit dazu, ein Keller, bis Zeit, also mal wieder für einen Kurzpass. Und den darf heute ich moderieren, nein nicht Max-Jakob Ost, der hat eine ganze Menge um die Ohren. Mit Bundesliga der Männer-der-Frauen-Ligatour, seine Lesetour ja auch noch und so weiter und so fort. Dafür darf ich ihn unterstützen, Nina Pozzel mein Name, genauso auch auf Twitter zu finden. Vielleicht kennt ihr mich ja schon als Gästin hier oder vom Podcast die 45. Da spreche ich jede Woche mit Spielerinnen aus der Bundesliga der Frauen über eben diese Liga oder mit anderen Akteurinnen auch. Und ich habe mir für heute drei Gästinnen eingeladen. Wir werden natürlich auch auf das Spitzenspiel schauen, zwischen Darmstadt 98 und dem Hamburger SV, aber natürlich auch wieder in den Keller, in dem sich die Vereine ja ziemlich auf den Füßen stehen. Und passend zum Samstagabendspiel Darmstadt gegen den HSV sind heute mit dabei Matthias Kneifl, Buchautor, Historiker, Blogger und Podcaster beim Ligien-Podcast Hoch und Weit auf Twitter zu finden, als Ed Kickschuh-Blog. Hi Matthias, schön, dass du da bist.
Hallo Nina, danke für die Einladung und servus, hallo zusammen, wie ich beim Hoch und Weit-Podcast gerne sage.
Sehr schön, war das alles richtig, was ich da aufgezählt habe?
Also Historiker stimmt schon. Sogar meine Abschlussarbeit damals zu einem sporthistorischen Thema gewählt, Fußball-Länderspiel 1950 bis 55 im Kontext der Außenpolitik der Bundesdeutschen, um den genüge zu tun. Aber mittlerweile bin ich längst Medienmensch, wie so viele in der Podcast-Szene und arbeite in einer Agentur.
Ich habe das nur bei Twitter gesehen, deswegen dachte ich Historiker. Find ich gut, kann man mit reinnehmen. In der anderen Ecke quasi, des Rings für das Spiel am Samstagabend, Tanja Hufschmidt vom HSV-Talk, manchmal auch bei Früff zu hören, F. Schmidt, 77, auf Twitter. Auch schön, dass du mit dabei bist, Tanja. Hi. Die 2. Bundesliga, die geht natürlich nicht ohne sie, das ist kaum vorstellbar. Aktuell leidet sie ganz schön mit im Keller mit, hat aber eben auch den besten Blick mit drauf. Eva-Lotta Bohle vom 2. Bundesliga-Podcast, in dem sie jede Woche über die 2. Bundesliga eben spricht, adefa-bohle, so rum, auf Twitter. Hi, Eva!
Das lief fast so häufig wie Bielefeld-Saison, dittum. Vielen, vielen Dank für die Einladung. Ich freue mich natürlich, wenn ich ausnahmsweise mal nicht so viel über meinen eigenen Verein sagen darf, aber wir haben ja alle Freude an dieser Liga. Manche Menschen mehr, manche Menschen weniger. Aber ich glaube, es ist einfach immer wieder spaßig, darüber zu reden und es kommen immer wieder neue Sachen dazu. Und sie haben uns, wie du ja schon gesagt hast, auch passend zwei Traineranpassungen besorgt.
Das war wirklich sehr witzig. Am Anfang der Woche war das noch zusammengeschrieben. Das kann lustig werden. Bevor wir wirklich loslegen mit dieser Folge, noch einmal der Hinweis, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Ihr könnt ihn aber gerne unterstützen über rasenfunk.de//taghashtag oh mein Gott. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub, so rum. Oder auch wenn ihr unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de Merch kauft. Der ist möglichst fair und nachhaltig produziert. Das sagt Max auch immer so und der hat da den Blick drüber. Also macht das sehr, sehr gerne, registriert euch da. Kauft euch Dinge aus dem Shop. Und wenn ihr das auch schon macht, registriert euch auch direkt mal als Supporterin. Da hat Max dann eine Mail von euch und kann euch danken, Updates schicken und so weiter. So ja zum Beispiel auch die Nachricht, dass der Rasenfunk eine GmbH ist. Das heißt, wenn ihr schon Supporterin seid, dann checkt mal nochmal, dass ihr die Kontoverbindung auch wirklich schon angepasst habt. Das könnt ihr unter rasenfunk.de/kontomachen. So, nun aber. Was haben wir heute vor? Wir besprechen tatsächlich relativ ähnliche Vereine wie in der letzten Folge im November. Entschuldigt das bitte, aber an der Spitze und im Keller, da geht es einfach ziemlich ab und Eva hat es ja auch schon gesagt. Da gibt es immer wieder was Neues. Da können wir also nicht drüber reden. Also wir schauen uns natürlich den Keller an, wobei wir uns auf vier Teams im Abstiegskampf fokussieren. Nürnberg, Magdeburg, Regensburg und Sandhausen. Hannover steht aktuell auf dem neunten Platz, also vor dieser Gruppe. Droht aber auch so ein bisschen mit in den Strudel zu rutschen, der ja sehr groß ist da in der zweiten Tabellenhälfte. Über die sprechen wir also auch. Wir legen aber los mit der Spitze. Natürlich mit dem SV Darmstadt 98, Hamburger SV. Heidenheim nehmen wir auch noch mit. Und SC Paderborn, da schauen wir auch noch mal kurz drauf. Und für eben dieses anstehende Spitzenspiel zwischen Darmstadt und dem HSV genau dafür habe ich mich schließlich Matthias und Tanja eingeladen. Und ich würde mal sagen, wir legen los mit dem erst platzierten Darmstadt. Die Darmständer, die können ja scheinbar nichts mehr wirklich falsch machen irgendwie. Sie haben nach wie vor ein einziges Liga-Spiel erst verloren. Das war am ersten Spieltag und seitdem sind sie ungeschlagen. Auch ins Jahr 2023 sind sie perfekt gestartet mit diesen vier Siegen. Abzug natürlich, DFB-Pokal, aber den klammern wir jetzt mal aus, wenn wir über die zweite Bundesliga sprechen. Ansonsten gab es aber eben Siege gegen Regensburg, Sandhausen, Draunschweig und Rostock. Wie geht es dir so damit, würde ich mal sagen? Sieht doch ganz gut aus. Wie happy bist du gerade mit deinen Jährchen?
Also es ist wirklich sehr, sehr gut. Jetzt hast du die Teams aufgezählt, gegen die wir, sage ich jetzt, in der Rückrunde bislang gewonnen hatten. Die sind natürlich samt und sonder in der zweiten Tabellenhälfte zu finden. Da könnte man gemeinten meinen, na ja, leichte Beute. Aber ich denke, das schlägt in der zweiten Liga definitiv fehl, der Gedanke. Weil unten wird schon auch geguckt, die Punkte zu sammeln, um nicht ganz schnell irgendwie ins Hintertreffen zu geraten. Insofern waren das keine einfachen Spiele, aber die wurden gegen Braunschweig schon sehr eng bestritten. Da war es so ein Sieg auf den letzten Drücker. Aber ansonsten war das dann doch im zunehmenden Spielverlauf, wie gegen Rostock oder von Anfang an, wie gegen Sandhausen und Regensburg ein Spiel, wo man wirklich gut einen Gewissens zugucken konnte und sichergehen konnte, dass wird gewonnen. Also diese Selbstverständlichkeit der ersten Saisonhüfte wurde tatsächlich mit rüber in dieses Neujahr gerettet nach einer sehr, sehr langen Winterpause. Darüber kann man nur wirklich sehr, sehr froh sein als Ligenanhänger. Wir nennen uns zwar im Podcast hoch und weit und wir wissen immer noch, einen guten langen Schlag zu schätzen, aber mittlerweile wissen wir auch, wie Flachpass-Spiel geht. Ich bin sehr, sehr angetan von der Entwicklung über die Jahre hinweg und auch jetzt noch mal in der Saison.
Ich wollte nämlich auch gerade fragen, erstens sagen, dass ich das auch total beeindruckend fand, dass man eben auch so durch schwierigere Phasen in einem Spiel ganz gut durchkommt. Wie du schon gesagt hast, gegen Rostock. Und was meintest du jetzt genau, kannst du uns das vielleicht mal beschreiben, diese Entwicklung auch innerhalb der Saison noch mal?
Also ich finde, klar, das erste Saisonspiel in Regensburg ging in die Hose sozusagen. Also gleich nach, ich glaube, wenigen Sekunden, das 0 zu 1. Einfach nicht aufgepasst, noch nicht auf dem Platz. Geistig, dann rote Karte gegen Patrick Pfeiffer. Dann war man dabei, sich ins Spiel zurückzukämpfen. 0 zu 2 und damit war der Käse gegessen sozusagen. Aber dann war so ein Abnutzungskampf gegen Sandhausen, den man noch 2-1 gewinnen konnte. Last-Minute-Sieg in Braunschweig und dann fing es langsam an zu laufen. Dann griffen so die Rädchen ineinander und die Entwicklung unter Lieberknecht war ja schon letzte Saison wirklich sehr, sehr bemerkenswert. Und wir haben den Kader durchaus zusammenhalten können. Also es gab zwei Abgänge, die ein bisschen weh taten. Ja, Luca Pfeiffer und Tim Skake. Dafür haben wir jetzt keine gestandenen Spieler verpflichtet, außer Christoph Zimmermann. Das war fast so der Königstransfer aus Norwich. Und ich finde, dadurch, dass man einfach auf einer guten, guten und breiten Basis aufsetzen konnte, war schon der beste Schritt, um die vergangene Saison, die vielleicht für manchen enttäuschend auf Platz 4 endete, aber dennoch ein großer Erfolg war, sich diesen positiven Vibe mitzuerhalten und dann auch mit in die neue Saison zu nehmen. Das geht oftmals nicht auf. Bei uns ging es auf und natürlich, wenn man sich die letzte Saison mit dieser Saison so ein bisschen vergleicht, die letzte Saison fanden wir auch schwer in der Spielzeit, allerdings durch Corona-bedingte Ausfälle auch mit erklärbar. Aber da hatten wir auch mal so Kantersiege gegen, ich glaube, Sandhausen, Ingolstadt, Auer, jeweils fünf oder sechs Tore und haben dann so uns ein bisschen in Horastik rein manövriert, auch auf Schalke mit einem 4 zu 2. Das ist dieses Jahr eher dosiert wahrnehmbar. Also die Mannschaft wirkt einfach reifer, macht den nächsten Schritt. Viele Spieler machen auch den nächsten Schritt, wie Melem, wie Schnellhardt, wie Yannick Müller. Und so kommt eins zum anderen.
Und das sieht dann ganz gut aus, wenn man sich das anguckt, dann nochmal bei Transfermarkt zum Beispiel, oder wenn man sich das selber markiert, ist alles sehr hübsch grün bei euch mit sehr vielen Siegen. Eva, du hattest in der letzten Folge, im letzten Kurzpass, ja auch gesagt, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, dass Darmstadt so ein bisschen ein Top-Torjäger fehlt. Philipp Dietz macht zumindest in den letzten zwei Spielen zwei Tore. Die Plätze hinter ihm dann aber bei den Torschützen bei Darmstadt sieht ein bisschen traurig aus, weil da ja viele verletzt sind aktuell. Wie will man das ausbaden?
Also es klingt natürlich immer ein bisschen merkwürdig, wenn man beim Tabellenführer irgendwie ankreidet, da fehlt jetzt ein Torjäger. Es ist ja manchmal einfach, keine Ahnung, wenn wir zum Beispiel über den Simon Terodde reden oder auch Fabi Kloss als Bielefeld aufgestiegen ist, ist es ja meistens so, ein Spieler, wo man sagt, wenn nach vorne wenig geht, mal in einem Spiel, wenn es einfach ein dreckiges Zweitliga-Spiel ist, wovon man ja einfach viel hat, dass dann mal nichts geht, dass man immer sagt, da gibt es einen Spieler, der dann immer vorangeht. Obwohl ich glaube ich damals auch, bzw. das muss man natürlich immer abschwächen, dadurch, dass gleichzeitig es auch heißen kann, dass in der Mannschaft an sich so viel Qualität ist. Also man braucht nicht die stärkste Offensive der Liga zu stellen, was ja immer noch parabornt tut. Es reicht halt, wenn man einen guten Plan nach vorne hat, einen vielseitigen Plan nach vorne. Und bei Darmstadt ist es natürlich auch so, dass jemand wie Tietz ja nicht nur aus dem Spiel heraus gefährlich ist, sondern auch einfach extrem durch Standards. Das hat man am Wochenende natürlich gegen Rostock wieder gesehen. Ich sage mal, in einem Spiel, wo es dann doch ein bisschen schwieriger war, dieses Rostocker-Boywerk gerade in Halbzeit 1 zu knacken, dann in Halbzeit 2 natürlich schon versucht wurde, durch eben Standards Druck aufzubauen. Und dann natürlich auch durch dieses Tietz-Tor, das dann auch einfach gelungen ist. Das heißt ja nicht, dass Darmstadt nur über Standards kommt, aber das kann halt einfach eine Waffe sein für ein Team, was vielleicht jetzt vergleichsweise zum HSV individuell jetzt nicht die Namen auf den Platz bringt. Also ohne das in irgendeiner Art und Weise respektlos zu meinen, aber nicht die individuelle Klasse vergleichbar auf den Platz bringt. Weil man trotzdem einfach weiß, worauf sie bauen können. Und man muss natürlich auch immer überlegen, ob es ein Torjäger in einem System von Thorsten Lieberknecht in dem Sinne jetzt braucht. Also brauche ich überhaupt jemanden wie beispielsweise Glatzel beim HSV oder ist alles darauf angelegt, dass sich jedes Spiel mit acht Toren gewinnt, so ungefähr? Und das muss Darmstadt ja auch einfach nicht, weil sie gewinnen ja ihre Spiele trotzdem. Und das ist das, was zählt und schaffen es damit ja auch am effektivsten, im Prinzip die Mannschaften hinter sich zu lassen. Worauf wir dann, glaube ich, oder ich damals auch so ein bisschen raus wollte, ist natürlich die Frage, was passiert halt mal, wenn mal etwas nicht klappt, also auch nicht über Standards, gibt es dann irgendwie einen, der dann diese Lücke füllen kann. Aber alleine zum Beispiel jemand wie Ronstadt oder so, der füllt das ja immer ganz gut. Von daher klang das natürlich, weiß auch, ein bisschen überspitzt formuliert damals, aber man sucht ja schon irgendwie immer so nach einem Top-Torjäger in dem Sinne, weil es natürlich die letzten Jahre eigentlich meistens auch Standard war, dass die Mannschaft, die den, oder ich glaube außer letztes Jahr, aber sonst natürlich oftmals so, dass die Mannschaft die aufsteigt, vor allem als ex-Blazierte meistens auch den klassischen Torjäger hat, wo ich aber wiederum dann auch noch mal sagen möchte, ich finde es gar nicht so schlimm, wenn man das nicht hat, weil man ja ganz oft sieht, dass dann eben Leute wie Tiroddo und Fabian Klos, oder auch ein Robert Glatzel, der zwischendurch bei Mainz war, dann auch gar nicht mal so direkt in der Bundesliga funktionieren und dann so einem Team natürlich auch irgendwie so ein bisschen den Plan A wegnehmen.
Da hacke ich vielleicht kurz mal ein. Philipp Tietz hat ja auch eine Rolle als Zielspieler, also sprich, er schafft dadurch auch wieder, weil er viele Bälle behauptet, Platz für andere und um ihn herum war in der Saison –jetzt ist er zwar gerade verletzt, aber Braden Manou auch –nicht so wie Pfeiffer im letzten Jahr, die dann echt eine gute Doppelspitze dargestellt haben, ich glaube 32 Toren in Summe. Und in der Saison davor war es Durzun allein mit 27. Also sowas haben wir jetzt in dem Maße nicht mehr, aber auch Manou, also freies Radikal um Tietz herum, die schaffen dann einfach auch Plätze oder Raume für andere, wo dann welche reinstechen können. Und jetzt auf Samstag zum Beispiel bezogen, da hatten wir tatsächlich in der ersten Halbzeit richtig Probleme mit dem zunehmenden Pressing von Hansa zurechtzukommen, haben es aber dann doch irgendwie geschafft, die nicht zu klaren Abschusschancen kommen zu lassen. Und diese defensive Stabilität ergibt dann wiederum, dass die meisten Siege mit einem Torunterschied ausfallen in der Saison, die dann aber doch nicht so spitze auf Knopf sind. Also jetzt, wenn man wirklich dieses Rostock-Spiel als Paradebeispiel nimmt, da gab es in der zweiten Halbzeit ja Chancen zu Hauf schon fast. Also einmal ein richtig langer Pass flach in die Spitze von Holland, da hätte glaube ich jeder Packing-Fanatiker entzückt auf den Sofa applaudiert, der glaube ich dann fünf Spieler aus dem Spiel genommen hat von Rostock. Und dann aber auch von außen kombiniert über Honsack, der dann im Endeffekt bei Honsack endet, der dann direkt eine Name macht, und die dann von Kolke gehalten wird. Und auch noch so eine Geschichte, in der der Latten-Treffer resultiert, was auch über rechts und Honsack seinen Ausgang nahm. Aber zum Schluss war es der Standard. Also das heißt, da war eigentlich schon der Siegtreffer in der Luft gelegen und dann muss es doch einen Standard richten. Aber auch das Standard-Thema ist sicherlich ein Faktor, aber auch nicht so ausgeprägt in meiner Beobachtung, wie es oft gemacht wird, auch von Medien. Also natürlich ist es immer ein probates Mittel, aber auch Kempe ist nicht frei von richtig schlechten Standards. Also auch das passiert. Und schlussendlich greift so doch vieles ineinander. Also was ich vielleicht noch sagen kann, wenn man dieses Jahr die Ligien betrachtet, nicht nur 2023, sondern die Gesamtsaison, dann steht immer eine Mannschaft auf dem Platz. Und natürlich gibt es ein Korsett, aber durch die zahlreichen Verletzten, da können wir vielleicht auch zum Ende hin noch mal drauf eingehen, schon am Ende der Hinrunde und jetzt schon wieder, rotieren immer wieder neue Spieler rein. Die erfüllen einfach ihre Aufgaben wirklich gut. Also es ist nie der Eindruck, oh jetzt haben wir aber echt ein paar Schwachstellen uns angelacht in dem Spiel, sondern die Mannschaft regelt das. Und das ist wirklich was, was die Mannschaft in dem Jahr kennzeichnet und auszeichnet. Und auch Mannschaftsumstellungen. Also wir sind auch relativ flexibel. Wir haben jetzt die Dreierkette in der Saison installiert, die gab es letztes Jahr noch nicht. Wir hatten letztes Jahr die Doppelspitze, die gab es da vorne noch nie bei Ligien, aber schon ewig nicht mehr. Und deshalb ist das auch was, was Leberknecht an Schnellschrauben dreht, die verfangen. Also es ist einfach irgendwie eine gute Kombi zwischen Trainer-Team und Mannschaft, die dann das, was das Trainer-Team vorgibt, umsetzt, auch mal im Spiel, wenn es eben in Rostock zuerst nicht funktioniert. Und dann musst du verletzungsbedingt Leute wie Müller rausnehmen und campen, die ja wirklich wichtig sind. Und bringst Benets rein und dann noch Riedel als 19-Jährigen. Und die spielen plötzlich sehr viel besser, haben mehr Zugriff. Tauschen die Außenverteidiger, sodass die anlaufenden Spieler plötzlich nicht mehr so einen richtigen Zugriff kriegen von Rostock. Und das funktioniert auch. Also die Mannschaft entwickelt sich mit dem Trainer-Team zusammen wirklich in eine total richtige Richtung.
Das ist auf jeden Fall voll positiv, dass man das eben so gut auffangen kann. Eva, du wolltest gerade was sagen?
Ja, was für sie selber super positiv ist, für alle Gegner natürlich super frustrierend ist, dass sie auch Einfaches drauf haben, schon vor Torerziehung oder mit dem Tor, dann spätestens, wenn sie in Führung gehen, so eine Dominanz auszustrahlen auf dem Platz, ohne danach jetzt noch 18 Schüsse aufs Tor zu haben, aber einfach durch die Präsenz auf dem Feld, einfach da hingehend etwas auszustrahlen, was es für den Gegner noch schwieriger macht. Klar ist es natürlich so, gerade in Vereinen wie Rostock, wie Braunschöck, die haben dann halt auch einfach nicht mehr die Mittel. Also ich sag dann mal so, wenn du oben bei einer Tabelle stehst, läuft dann so ein Spiel in der Tät. Das ist einfach so, läuft dann natürlich auch eher für dich. Wenn du unten stehst, eher gegen dich, gibt ja auch immer Gründe, dass da eben die Qualität fehlt. Aber und ich muss auch da sagen, dass Darmstadt sich da in der Saison auch weiterentwickelt hat, also dass es da noch mal genauer gab. Also ich weiß halt zum Beispiel nur beim Spiel gegen Bielefeld, dass man da halt irgendwann zu sehr nachgelassen hat damals, dass man den Gegner komplett unnötigerweise halt überhaupt rankommen lassen hat, auch wenn der Ausbleich dann erst zu spät fröngelt. Aber da hat das so ein bisschen gefehlt. Und das haben sie aber einfach unfassbar gut hinbekommen. Und das ist einfach eine Qualität. Und das ist eben das, was aufsteigert, die eben nicht diese typischen –ich sage jetzt mal wie letzte Saison Schalke Werder oder so –also dieses klassische Big-Names-Mäßig, das auch die letzten Jahre immer wieder ausgezeichnet hat, dass sie in solchen Spielen in irgendeinem Fall einfach –du wusstest einfach, die verlieren das jetzt nicht mehr. Das hatten VfL Bochum damals auch gezeigt, die Spielvereinigung. Die konnten das dann einfach alle immer irgendwann, dass man irgendwann gemerkt hat, okay, es geht aber auch nicht mehr. Hier ist kein Weg mehr nach vorne. Und das ist, glaube ich, das, was für alle anderen Gegner ist, das auch so frustrierend macht, eben gegen Darmstadt zu spielen.
Ja, das ist ein guter Punkt. Also gerade die Phase, wo du erwähnst mit dem Bielefeldspiel in der Hinrunde, da war auch Kaiserslautern drumrum. Also in Kaiserslautern hatten sie vermeintlich sicher geführt. Und dann hat Kaiserslautern so ein bisschen wildes Auge gespielt, das Publikum angezogen und dann stand es plötzlich 2-3 für Kaiserslautern. Und dann dachte sie sich, ja, das ist jetzt kaputt. Und dann macht Seidel nochmal einen Gegentreffer. Dann war es schlussendlich in Remy. Und da in der Nähe war auch das Bielefeldspiel. Da hast du den Treffer von Hack, der dann quasi der Last-Minute-Treffer war in der Nachspielzeit, wo das Stadion sich gedacht hat, wie geht das jetzt? Also da hat es einfach das Team versäumt, rechtzeitig klare Verhältnisse zu schaffen. Und es hat es danach besser in den Griff gekriegt. Also da gab es gegen Dürrenberg ein 2 zu 0. Das stand im Endeffekt nach einer halben Stunde fest. Und man hätte auch abpfeifen können, da passiert nicht mehr viel. Nürnberg konnte nicht, wir wollten nicht. Und da gab es aber auch schon so ein bisschen Gespräche auf der Tribüne. Was ist denn heute los? Es ist ja irgendwie langweilig. Aber das war die richtige Schlussfolgerung, das eben frühzeitig so abzusichern, dass da nichts mehr passiert.
Sehr erwachsen dann auch, was du auch schon gesagt hast, dass es mal irgendwie reifer wird. Dann wollen wir mal ein bisschen weiter gucken. Es geht eben weiter gegen den HSV, dann gegen Heidenheim und gegen Bielefeld in den nächsten drei Spielen. Und wenn ihr jetzt gesagt habt, man merkt es einfach, da brennt nichts mehr an, der Gegner hat dann nicht mehr wirklich eine Chance. Tanja, holen wir dich mal mit ins Boot für den HSV. Geht dir das auch ähnlich so? Also der HSV, um das mal auch rund zu machen, der HSV ist mit drei Siegen und einem Unentschieden in dieses Jahr gestartet. Hat eben gegen Braunschweig, Rostock und die Arminia gewonnen. Gegen Heidenheim dieses vollkommen absurde 3 zu 3 nach 0-3-Rückstand noch gemacht. Sportlich läuft es ganz gut. Es gibt ein paar Nebenschauplätze natürlich, über die werden wir auch noch reden. Aber erstmal Tanja, wie geht es dir so mit Blick auf Darmstadt? Hast du dieses Gefühl, wenn die mal ins Rollen kommen, dann haben wir keine Chance? Oder sagst du, wir brechen die?
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir sie brechen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass wir chancenlos nach Darmstadt fahren. Also ich glaube, es wird ein wirklich interessantes Spiel. Spätestens für die Taktiker wird es auf jeden Fall interessant. Und dann muss man sehen, wie bei uns ist immer das Problem, die haben zwar die individuelle Klasse, haben aber auch dann zwischendurch mal so ein bisschen ein Schlendern drin, dass sie einfach unkonzentriert sind, dass sie dann nicht richtig in die Zweikämpfe dann reinkommen. Es sieht immer so aus, als würden sie einen Schritt zu spät kommen. Und das ist halt immer die Frage, wie kommen sie jetzt tatsächlich ins Spiel rein? Wie kommen sie mit dem Gegner klar? Wie kommen sie mit Gegenpressing klar? Das ist immer so ein bisschen offen. Aber wenn sie dann erstmal wirklich ins Laufen kommen, das hat Heidenheim innerhalb von 20 Minuten erlebt, was dann passiert.
Das stimmt. Meinst du, diese vielen Ausfälle bei Darmstadt könnte das eine Chance sein für den HSV?
Glaube ich nicht. Wie Matthias ja auch schon gesagt hat, die können das immer gut auffangen. Und wenn sie da wirklich mannschaftlich geschlossen auch die ganze Zeit agieren und ihren Plan durchziehen, dann sind wir da jetzt nicht so die Übermannschaft, die da nadenlos das Kapital draus schlagen wird.
Ja, da kann ich vielleicht noch was anfügen. Gerade am Ende der Hinrunde hatte ich vorhin schon angemerkt, waren wir echt auf Reserve gelaufen. Mit vielen Verletzten. Honsack hat in der Hinrunde ja gar nicht gespielt. Igas Sula schnell hart waren, relativ schnell außen rennen. Seidel ohnehin immer wieder verletzungsanfällig. Da kam es aber auch zu pass, dass wir drei Spiele in Folge hatten, wo der Gegner dezimiert war. Die haben alle Platzverweise kassiert, in Magdeburg höchst umstritten. Und dann reichte eben ein Schuss, um quasi den Dreier oder zumindest einen Punkt mitzunehmen. Jetzt wird es aber wirklich langsam kritisch. Ich zähle mir auf, wer alles nicht spielen wird. Aaron Seidel, Seelandriss im Oberschenkel, Patrick Pfeiffer, Muskelbündelriss, Igas Sula, Adduktorenreizung steigt wohl wieder ins Training ein, aber hat das letzte Spiel im September gemacht. Bader, Unterleibs-OP, Manu, muskuläre Probleme, keine Ahnung, was das bedeutet. Kempe, Inbandriss, Müller, Fuselfaseriss, das sind schon gewichtige Faktoren im Ligenspiel. Ich habe mir auch noch mal die Kicker-Analyste zur Saison-Heldzeit angeguckt. Manu war unter den besten drei Angreifern, ist jetzt quasi erst mal angeschlagen. Kempe war Nummer 1 im defensiven Mittelfeld, steht nicht zur Verfügung. Pfeiffer war Nummer 1 in der Innenverteidigung, steht nicht zur Verfügung. Bader war Nummer 2 in der Außenverteidigung, steht auch nicht zur Verfügung. Das sind keine No-Names, das sind schon wirklich Korsett-Stangen im Ligien-Spiel. Bislang haben sie es erstaunlich gut wegstecken können, aber durch Kemper und Müller haben sie zwei nochmal empfindliche Ausfälle in Rostock dazugewonnen. Das macht mir schon Sorge, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, dass irgendwann mal da wirklich das aufgebraucht ist, was man sich jetzt so immer noch herangezogen hat. Und deshalb, ja, HSV hat auch, glaube ich, in Darmstadt noch nie verloren. Also Tanja, die Statistik spricht für euch. Wir holen eher die Punkte bei euch. Aber ja, die Verletzungen machen mir schon Sorge, weil es jetzt auch keine Laparien sind. Die stehen nicht in zwei Wochen wieder auf dem Feld. Das gilt zu kompensieren. Ich frage mich nur langsam, wie, weil am Sonntag oder am Samstagabend werden sich sicherlich U19-Spieler auf der Bank wiederfinden.
Aber ich denke mal, zumindest mein Gefühl bei euch ist, dass Liebertnecht auch ein System spielen lässt, das die Spieler wirklich gut verinnerlicht haben. Sodass man halt wirklich dann auch Jungs reinschmeißen kann, die dann einfach diese Rolle in dem Augenblick übernehmen können.
Ja, ging Rostock tatsächlich auf. Gleichwohl. Ich glaube, so langsam gehen die Optionen aus, auch variabler zu agieren. Aus der Bank noch irgendwie etwas nachzulegen. Aber lassen wir uns überraschen, es wird auf jeden Fall ein Highlight.
Absolut. Und eine perfekte Zeit dann auch am Samstagabend. Ich finde es beim HSV in dieser Saison, ich meine natürlich ist es ganz oft beim HSV so, jetzt kommt langsam der Frühling, warten wir mal ab, wie das wird. Dieser Running-Gag quasi kommt der Frühling, geht es beim HSV bergab. Aber ich habe so das Gefühl, und das ist ja auch schon ganz oft Thema gewesen, dass es dieses Jahr irgendwie alles so ein bisschen reifer wirkt schon. Das sieht man ja auch, sie kommen nach diesem 0 zu 3 krass zurück. Die bringen auch Siege über die Zeit, wenn sie zum Beispiel mit der gegnerischen Spielweise jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig gut zurechtkommen. Also gegen die Arminia zum Beispiel haben sie sich jetzt nicht so leicht getan teilweise. Das gibt ja auf jeden Fall Hoffnung, ne Tanja?
Klar, also man merkt wirklich, dass die Mannschaft größtenteils zusammengeblieben ist, dass auch der Trainer geblieben ist. Das kennt man ja in Hamburg normalerweise nicht so, zumindest nicht in Zweitliga-Zeiten. Und da greift dann halt auch wirklich allmählich so ein Rad ins andere. Und das System von Tim Walter ist sehr anspruchsvoll. Und du merkst halt, wie die Spieler da immer mehr reinwachsen. Das sind teilweise sehr junge Spieler, also Ludovic Reis ist Anfang 20. Und was der jetzt in den anderthalb Jahren beim HSV für eine Entwicklung genommen hat, das ist schon bemerkenswert. Und das siehst du halt, das klappt immer besser. Das hat man zum Beispiel auch am Wochenende gegen Bielefeld gesehen beim Führungstreffer, dass dann plötzlich mit der Hacke einfach in eigentlich total leeren Raum gespielt wird. Aber da sprintet dann Reis genau in diesen Raum rein und holt sich den Ball und er zählt dann dadurch das 1 zu 0. Das ist, da merkt man, das wächst zusammen. Das hilft auch wirklich, dass mal kein kompletter Umbruch irgendwie stattgefunden hat, dass kein neuer Trainer eine neue Idee hat, sondern dass einfach konstant weiter gearbeitet wird und die Spieler sich weiterentwickeln.
Ich finde das auch ein sehr guter Punkt, weil Tim Walter jetzt auch vier Transferperioden mitgestalten konnte. Das ist ja auch wichtig, dass er auch das Spielerpersonal bekommt, das ihm maßgeblich taugt, um es herauszuformulieren. Deshalb bin ich da komplett bei Tanja, dass das sich auch niederschlägt. Gerade auch das Spiel in Heidenheim, wenn du so ein Rückstandbett machst, das kann so ein positiver Impuls für die restliche Saison sein.
Und einen Neuzugang möchte ich auf jeden Fall noch mal hervorheben. Andras Nemec hat zwar erst 30 Minuten gespielt, aber 2 Tore schon gemacht. Das fand ich sehr, sehr stark. Aus Genk ist er gekommen, auch gerade 20 Jahre alt erst. Mittelstürmer schon noch drin. Schon nicht schlecht.
Ja, wir sind auch alle positiv überrascht. So richtig einschätzen kann ich ihn tatsächlich noch nicht nach 30 Spielminuten, klar. Aber er hat sich da schnell zurechtgefunden und sagt auch, hey, ich kann hier von Robert Latze gut was lernen, also gucke ich mir das einfach mal an und mach das hier. Und es scheint ein guter Junge zu sein.
Bist du auch insgesamt zufrieden, was in der Winterpause, in der ja doch sehr, sehr lange Winterpause passiert ist, beim HSV?
Also so von den Neuzugängen, dass wir überhaupt im Winter Neuzugänge haben, ist ja relativ selten. Aber das passt schon. Also es ist punktuell verbessert worden, weil Mario Vuskovic, wissen wir alle nicht, wie lange der ausfällt. Deswegen wurde ein zusätzlicher Innenverteidiger geholt. Völlig logisch. Dann, dass wir auf den Außen, vor allen Dingen auf der linken Außenbahn, dann durch den kurzfristigen Abgang von Tim Leibold noch mal eine Planstelle offen hatten und dadurch die dann durch die Laie von Noah Katterbach schließen konnten, ist auch eine gute Option. Und dass wir ein Backup für Robert Glatzel brauchen, war auch eigentlich von Anfang der Saison schon klar. Und dass sich da, wie jetzt halt mit Nemeth, sowas ergeben hat, super. Also mit der Transfer, mit dem Transferfenster jetzt im Winter, bin ich sehr zufrieden.
Auf jeden Fall. Nemeth ist sehr spannend zu beobachten. Tim Leibold, nur der Vollständigkeit halber, ist in die USA nach Kansas City gewechselt. Und du hast es ja auch schon angesprochen, Stichwort Wuschkewitsch, der ja immer noch dieses Doping-Verfahren an der Backe kleben hat. Der HSV unterstützt ihn ja weiter, nicht wahr? Der wurde ja positiv auf EPO getestet. Die B-Probe war mittlerweile auch positiv. Er hat sich fünf Anwälte geholt, vier eigene Gutachten auch in Auftrag gegeben, die alle sagen, die Probe war negativ. Bei EPO ist es wohl so, dass man da keine genauen Werte –ich bin keine Expertin für Doping, aber das ist das, was ich gelesen habe –keine genauen Werte hat, sondern das sind Bilder, die man interpretieren muss.
Das habe ich auch erst in den vergangenen Wochen gelernt. Wir haben uns ja alle vorher nicht großartig mit Doping auseinandergesetzt, glaube ich. Aber das klingt alles irgendwann ziemlich merkwürdig, dass da irgendwelche bildgebenden Verfahren sind. Dann kommt es darauf an, wie man die jetzt mit Photoshop oder mit so einem Programm bearbeitet. Ob man da jetzt irgendwo irgendwelche Punkte sieht oder die Punkte Schatten werfen oder wie auch immer. Das ist alles sehr kompliziert und irgendwie nicht so richtig eindeutig. Mario Vuskovic sagt selber, er weiß nicht, wie das Zeug in seinen Körper gekommen sein sollte.
Was halt bei Epomissen schwierig ist, wenn es intravenös ist.
Genau. Er war in den Proben danach immer negativ. Nur diese eine ist halt positiv. Ich weiß tatsächlich nicht mehr, was ich denken soll. Normalerweise sage ich, da ist eine A- und eine B-Probe positiv. Also hat dieser Mensch gedobt. Aber wenn ich dann höre, irgendwie, ja, aber, da gibt es ja überhaupt keine Grenzwerte. Das ist eine Bildinterpretation. Bildinterpretation habe ich in der Schule schon gehasst. Also, weiß ich nicht. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das ausgehen wird. Und ich habe auch keine Ahnung, was da jetzt tatsächlich dahinter steckt.
Das heißt vor allen Dingen erst mal abwarten. Der Ursteilsspruch wurde auch vertagt. Am 10. März geht es da weiter und gibt es da vielleicht ein paar Infos. Noch eine andere Sache, was auch noch so ein Nebenschauplatz ist beim HSV, ist ja mal wieder Klaus Michael Kühne, der auf der Hauptversammlung der HSV AG, die ja abgebrochen worden ist, schon so ein paar Brenner gesetzt hat, sage ich mal. Der hat unter anderem auch noch verlauten lassen, es gibt momentan zwei Fraktionen, die Schlacht ist noch nicht geschlagen. Mit den zwei Fraktionen meint er auch, dass er eben Marcel Jansen gegenüber steht. Tanja, kannst du uns da erklären, was genau da los ist? Oder denkst du dir mittlerweile wirklich einfach, die sollen das machen, wir gucken auf den Sport?
Wie viel Zeit habt ihr?
Ich habe den noch am Zeit, du.
Also es ist tatsächlich ein bisschen komplizierter. Es ging eigentlich damit los, dass vor einem Jahr wurde von Marcel Jansen oder vom Aufsichtsrat insgesamt Thomas Wüstefeld in den Vorstand entsendet, der auch schon Anteile von Klaus-Michael Kühner abgekauft hat und sagen wir es so, die Entsendung lief nicht gerade positiv. Auf vielen Ebenen und vor allen Dingen lief es dann darauf hinaus, dass sich Kühne und Wüstefeld sehr zerstritten haben und das wohl auch vor Gericht gehen wird. Und dadurch ist Kühne jetzt auch in Opposition zu Marcel Jansen, der immer Wüstefeld so gestützt hat. Und da hast du jetzt so eine Fraktion. Und niemand weiß so genau. Es wurde dann auf der Mitgliederversammlung die ganze Zeit davon geredet, dass das ja alles nur von den Medien hochgepusht wurde und dass da eigentlich alles Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen ist. Glaubt nun mittlerweile keiner mehr. Aber ja, und dass Klaus Michael Kühne wieder mehr Macht beim HSV haben will oder da noch Geld reinschießen will, das ist bekannt. Er kommt mit seinen Plänen, wird da nicht durchkommen. Er will mehr Anteile haben. Irgendwie will er 39% dann halten. Wird er nicht kriegen, weil jetzt in der AG sagt die Satzung, bei mehr als 24,9% verkauften Anteilen muss erstmal die Mitgliedschaft zustimmen. Und die Mehrheit wird er nicht kriegen. Dann ist jetzt in der Diskussion, dass es noch mal einen Strukturwandel geben soll, dass von der AG in eine KGAA umgewandelt werden soll. Das wird aber auch frühestens in einem Jahr so weit sein, wenn nicht eher in eine 1,5 Jahre. Auch da sehe ich nicht, dass der HSV die Forderungen von Kühne erfüllen kann und will.
Alles kompliziert beim HSV. Auch wenn es sportlich aktuell sehr gut aussieht, so gut vielleicht wie in den letzten Jahren nicht. Weiter geht es mit dem Topspiel am Samstagabend. Wir können es wirklich nicht oft genug sagen. Gegen Darmstadt, Samstagabend. Und danach geht es gegen Nürnberg und Karlsruhe. Das dürfte auch interessant werden. Schauen wir mal weiter auf den dritten Platz. Heidenheim, vielleicht nicht ganz so lange wie jetzt die Darmstädter und Hamburger. Heidenheim ist irgendwie –ich weiß nicht. Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich weiß nicht genau, wie ich das einschätzen soll. Also gestartet mit einem Sieg gegen Rostock, dann gab es eine Niederlage gegen Braunschweig, dieses 3 zu 3 gegen den HSV, wo man sagen kann, ey, 3 zu 3 gegen den HSV, aber eben auch nach 0 zu 3 Führung. Und dann eben diese 5 zu 0 Klatsche für, also die Klatsche, die man dem 1. FC Nürnberg zugefügt hat. Das ist irgendwie –ich weiß nicht. Eva, was meinst du? Die sind ja schon in den letzten Jahren immer sehr gut mit dabei. Die Heidenheimer, das letzte Mal 19, 20 in der Saison, auch in der Relegation gewesen. Und jetzt startet man so irgendwie nach der Winterpause wieder, obwohl alles schon so sehr gut aussieht, nach dem Relegationsplatz fix am Ende. Was hältst du davon? Was machen wir jetzt damit?
Ja, mit Heidenheim ist es ja tatsächlich immer so ein bisschen kompliziert, weil ich muss gestehen, vor dieser Saison habe ich es gewagt, mal anzufragen, wie lange das wohl noch mit Frank Schmidt geht, weil bei Heidenheim ist es immer so, natürlich landen die Info immer in der oberen Tabellenhälfte, die müssen sich keine Gedanken um Abstiegskampf in dem Sinne machen, wenn man das jetzt vergleichsweise mit dem SV Sonthausen, die ja immer gegen den Abstieg kämpfen mussten, oder auch in den vergangenen Jahren Erzgebirge Aue, alles Mannschaften, die eigentlich immer, oder gerade Heidenheim und Sonthausen, die schon super lange in dieser Liga spielen, Ja, es gibt auch ein paar Spiele, die immer so ein bisschen als, ich sag mal, negativ Beispiel gelten, wenn man aus der Bundesliga absteigt, so ne, dann müsste man Heidenhain im Sandhausen, so. Und bei Heidenhain war ich letzte Saison zwischendurch irgendwie nicht mehr so ganz sicher, ob es da dahingeht überhaupt noch, also wo es mit denen irgendwie noch hingeht, wo es mit Frank Schmidt noch hingeht. Dann muss ich aber sagen, dass man, also wurde ich auch eines Besseren gelehrt, weil man gerade mit Janiklas Beste da wirklich den perfekten Spieler für Heidenhain gefunden hat, das Kleindienst wieder mehr und mehr in seine Rolle zurückfindet. Das war natürlich ein absoluter Glücksgriff für Heidenhain und natürlich auch strategisch sehr gut geplant. Und von daher würde ich sagen, also erstens ist es nicht so ungewöhnlich, dass Heidenhain auswärts verliert. Sie haben das so ein bisschen eingestellt diese Saison, dass man ein ganz klares Heidenheim zu Hause, Heidenheim auswärts hatte. Es ist nach wie vor super schwierig für Mannschaften bei Heidenheim zu bestehen, weil sie eben auch eine absolute Struktur haben. Und anders als jetzt bei anderen Vereinen –ich sage das immer so, ich meine das nicht respektlos –aber Heidenheim ist jetzt nicht im Kopf als der Kessel zu Hause durch die Fans. Das ist halt einfach nicht so, das ist gerade an dem Standpunkt auch unfassbar schwierig, da irgendwas zu kreieren. Aber jeder, der auch irgendwie mal dahin gefahren ist, weiß, dass es trotzdem unfassbar schwierig ist, irgendwie zum Stadion zu bestehen, weil du einfach auch einen Trainer hast, der vergleichsweise bei Christian Streich beim St. Freiburg einfach weiß, was er macht. Der gibt den Spielern eine relativ klare Linie vor und es ist irgendwann super schwierig, da durchzubrechen. Dieses 3-3 gegen Hamburg, witzigerweise macht 20.23 vor allem, dass wir drei Nullführungen einfach nicht mehr trauen sollten. Wir hatten am letzten Wochenende Kiel gegen Braunschweig, ich war schon mal bei Magdeburg, das war das Spiel davor, wo Kiel auch super easy mit drei Nullen eigentlich da steht und man sagt, das ist ja eigentlich der klassische Punkt, wo die KommentatorInnen im Fernsehen sagen, ich glaube, wir können Deckel drauf machen und es dann aber komplett, und bis dahin auch eine komplette Dominanz gezeigt hat, genauso wie bei Heidenheim gegen den HSV, dann sagt der gegnerische Trainer, wir machen jetzt zwei, drei Wechselreihen da und da und jetzt los und dann auch in Heidenheim nichts mehr entgegenzusetzen hat. Das Ding ist aber einfach, dass die das mit so einer Ruhe diese Saison durchspielen können, ja dann spielen sie halt mal 3-3 gegen den HSV, gewinnen halt die Woche drauf 5-0 gegen den Nürnberg, was sowieso kein wirklicher Gegner auf dem Platz ist, aber trotzdem Heidenheim scheißegal ist, dass Nürnberg zur Halbzeit defensiver agiert und dann machen sie trotzdem noch zwei Tore. Weil die das einfach können, aber weil die auch einfach null Druck haben. Niemand geht in diese Saison rein, also auf jeden Fall nichts, was man öffentlich mitkriegt und sagt, aber dieses Jahr wollen wir mal aussteigen. Ich finde es immer ein bisschen schade, weil ich würde tatsächlich gerne mal eine Saison sehen, wo der FC Heidenheim als erster, also der Zweite-Liga, absteigt, weil dieses Argumente, die wollen wir jetzt hier nicht auch noch in der Bundesliga haben. Ja, es tut mir leid, Leute, also das Problem ist ein ganz anderes, warum die Bundesliga im Zweifel nicht mehr attraktiv ist. Und manchmal glaube ich halt, dass es halt fehlt, dass es da wirklich eine Fanbase gibt, die das halt auch wirklich mal antreibt, dass man halt sagen kann, ey, wir spielen seit Jahren da oben mit. Das ist vollkommen legitim zu sagen, wir gehen jetzt mit dem Ziel, nee, dieses Jahr wollen wir aber mal aufsteigen rein. Und da muss ich halt sagen, dass dieses Jahr das gewesen wäre, wo du es wahrscheinlich am ehesten ankündigen kannst, weil der SV, ohne das jetzt komisch zu meinen, aber natürlich lange nicht mehr in dem Sinne, der dieser Big Name war, wie jetzt Werder und Schalke letztes Jahr als Absteiger. So und du hattest natürlich nicht diese Big Name-Absteiger dieses Jahr mit Bielefeld und führt. So, das heißt, du hättest es tatsächlich dieses Jahr mal richtig angehen können. Und klar, die Transfers gehen auch in die Richtung. Aber man hat immer so ein bisschen das Gefühl, ja, Vogelwildes 5-4 gegen Regensburg. So, bevor man in die Pause gegangen ist, wo man sich jetzt Regensburg anguckt, man denkt so, wie haben die vier Tore geschossen? Aber die können einfach, also die fliegen halt unterm Radar, werden halt auch nicht da eingehen beachtet. Alle acht Wochen gibt es irgendwie mal einen Skyfeature, wo die dann wieder auf Frank Schmidt eingehen und auf Tim Kleindienst. Und das war es aber. So, die können in Ruhe arbeiten, aber vielleicht manchmal auch zu in Ruhe.
Ja, ich glaube, da würde ich auch noch mal einhaken oder meine Meinung dazu abgeben. Ich finde, dass Heidenheim schon ein Club ist, der tatsächlich mal in der Reihe wäre. Also, sie spielen jetzt die neunte Saison der 2. Liga. Hab gestern mal nachgeguckt, waren nur zweimal schlechter als Platz 8. Und ich glaube, die sind damals auch mit den Lilien aus der 3. Liga nach oben gegangen. Da waren sie schon ein sehr ambitionierter Club. Also, die schließen jetzt sozusagen regional die Lücke, die Ulm und allen ihnen geöffnet hat. Und sie haben ja auch einen, glaube ich, breiten, lokal verankerten Sponsoring-Pool. Also, mit Freud und Hatmann und Konsorten haben sie da auch gewichtige Mittelständler oder Hitten Champions am Start. Und eben die Kontinuität, auch das, was wir vorhin beim HSV in New York haben ansprechen können, das ist hier natürlich Fakt. Also, auf dem Trainerstuhl. Aber sie haben auch wichtige Korsett-Stangen im Team, wie Müller im Tor oder Meinkai in der Innenverteidigung, die auch schon lange Jahre da sind. Kleindienst mit einem kurzen Intermezzo kam wieder zurück und Beste passt wirklich wie die Faust aufs Auge. Also, was Besseres konnte ihnen gar nicht passieren. Da musste man sich ja schon fast vor der Saison fragen, wie sie gewinnen konnten, Heidenheim, ihnen für ihr Team sozusagen zu gewinnen und andere auszustechen. Und ich finde, wenn man gegen Heidenheim spielt, dann hat man es in der Regel wirklich vor allem natürlich bei ihnen mit einer sehr, sehr disziplinierten Mannschaft zu tun, die einen wirklich mal überfahren kann mit ihrer Wucht. Und ich kann mich noch erinnern, dass es vor ein paar Jahren schon mal hieß, die Ligien müssen nach Heidenheim, die haben Hybridrasen. Da hat die Mannschaft wohl auch mal auf Kunstrasen trainiert, die Ligien, um sich irgendwie auch an das Geläuf so ranzutasten. Jetzt habe ich gestern auch gelesen, Hybridrasen gibt es mittlerweile an mehreren Standorten, also es ist kein Alleinstellungsmerkmal mehr. Aber Heidenheim ist auf jeden Fall in Heidenheim mega unangenehm. Auswärts haben sie freilich noch ein bisschen Luft nach oben, aber dennoch, ich finde, die muss man auf der Rechnung haben. Wer die klein redet, der hat ein Problem.
Also wir haben es ja jetzt auch gerade 70 Minuten lang erlebt. Erstens, wie wahnsinnig laufstark die sind. Ich meine, die laufen die meisten Kilometer der ganzen Liga. Das ist Wahnsinn. Und die spielen halt auch ein unglaublich intensives Pressing dabei und haben sehr effektives Flügelspiel dabei. Und das ist schon alles richtig gut geplant von Frank Schmidt. Und dass der sich halt nicht abnutzt, das ist ein absolutes Phänomen. Und ich finde auch, ich sage mal, ich gönne ihnen die Relegation.
Bitte nur nicht mit Corona und ohne Kochtöpfe und Kugeln.
Ja, noch kurz zu Jan-Niklas Bärste, der war ja auch bei Werder ganz lange. Und das war auch immer so ein kleines Sorgenkind, weil alle irgendwie schon auch große Hoffnungen hatten. Aber der war, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, auch nicht immer –wie soll man sagen –die Motivation war nicht immer die beste. Und er hatte da auch –ich glaube, in Regensburg gab es ja auch so ein paar Storys, deswegen der nie so richtig angekommen ist irgendwo. Deswegen freut mich das auch total für ihn, dass er jetzt in Heidenheim da so angekommen ist. Gegen Bielefeld am Wochenende kann er jetzt auch wieder zeigen, wie es geht.
Muss nicht, also muss wirklich nicht.
Danach geht es gegen Darmstadt, das wird auch sehr spannend. Das nächste sehr hochklassige Spiel.
Ein Doubleheader für uns mit den beiden Rivalen an der Tabellenspitze.
Absolut. Und dann geht es nach Düsseldorf für Heidenheim. Und wir gehen weiter zu Paderborn, die da auf dem vierten Platz stehen. Die waren nicht ganz weit weg von den Top-3. Das sind jetzt 10 Punkte, glaube ich, hinter Darmstadt. Aber die schleichen sich trotzdem so langsam ran. Die haben jetzt auch alle vier Spiele dieses Jahr gewonnen. Die sind auch nie zu ziel. Zwei Mal mit nur einem Tor. Und wie gesagt, auch eins der Teame, die nur mit Siegen ins neue Jahr gestartet sind. Das wird richtig eng da oben. Tanja, weißt du, warum die so viele Tore schießen?
Das Faszinierende bei Paderborn ist ja, das machen die schon seit Jahren. Das haben die auch schon früher gemacht. Als Baumgartner noch Trainer war, dass sie dann Spiele eher mit 4 zu 3 als mit 1 zu 0 gewonnen haben. Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum man in Paderborn so gut Tore schießen kann, aber scheint gut zu funktionieren. Es gibt auch durchaus Spieler bei Paderborn, die ich mir auch gut beim HSV vorstellen könnte. Das sind teilweise junge Spieler, die sich noch entwickeln können. Auf jeden Fall mit Schallenberg oder Leiparz. Die sind wirklich –okay, Leiparz ist jetzt nicht gerade jung, aber Piringa vorne drin, der ist noch relativ jung. Das sind interessante Spieler und ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die die immer herholen und finden und aufbauen.
Vielleicht –was auch erstaunlich ist, dass Quasniok so nahtlos die Baumgart-Politik fortsetzt. Zumindest, wenn man es auf dem Papier betrachtet. Ich glaube, dann ist man auch am Stande, Spieler zu gewinnen und davon zu überzeugen, es doch mal in Paderborn zu probieren, die irgendwie offensiv ihre Stärken sehen. Für mich ist Michelia so ein Beispiel, der in Karlsruhe als sehr junger Spieler schon auf sich aufmerksam gemacht hat. Dann bei Hannover irgendwie stagnierte und phasenweise nur noch kurzfristig ins Spiel geworfen wurde. Das hat mich in Hannover sehr verwundert. Jetzt zeigt er wieder, was er kann. Offenbar wird in den Gesprächen, wenn es darum geht, Spieler zu verpflichten, auch darauf hingewiesen. Seht mal zu, was wir hier in den letzten Jahren veranstalten. Wenn du auch ein Teil davon sein willst, dann herzlich willkommen. Aber sie bieten sich ja auch gar nicht beim obersten Regal. Sie holen sich viele Spieler aus der Regionalliga. Schallenberg kam damals aus Werl, ist aber in Parduan groß geworden. Oder auch Juxtván und Heuer von Wolfsburg II. Hofmeier jetzt vor der Saison von Preuß und Münster. Die hatten alle keine 2- oder 3-Liga-Erfahrung und kommen sofort an. Es ist auch eine Qualität, dass man offenbar so einen Rahmen bilden kann, indem die Spieler, die man von unterklassigen Clubs holt, ihre Qualitäten wiederum zur Geltung bringen. Da muss ich auch sagen, Chapeau. Das ist wirklich auffällig.
Ja, und da muss man natürlich auch ganz klar mal auf die Position des Sportgeschäftsführers gucken. Es wird ganz oft über Baumgart oder Kvassniok geredet, aber man muss ja auch mal sehen, Markus Krösche, der inzwischen über Umwege bei Frankfurt gelandet ist, Fabian Wohlgemuth. Da hatte Paderborn noch den Vertrag verlängert, der jetzt Sven Mislintat beim VfB Stuttgart abgelöst hat. Und jetzt Benjamin Weber, der mit dem Transfer von Humphreys da auch direkt ein bisschen eingegriffen hat, der jetzt zwar zwischendurch auch verletzt war, aber auch im ersten Spiel direkt eine Rolle gespielt hat, direkt diese Kvassniok-DNA mit reingebracht hat. Also ich meine, ich bin halt einfach kein großer Fan von Leuten wie Kvassniok und Baumgart. Das ist halt eher so mein persönliches Empfinden. Aber gleichzeitig ist es natürlich auch einfach so, dass man anerkennen muss, dass es funktioniert, sodass die Spiele durchaus unterhaltsam sind. Und eben gerade jemanden wie Leiparz, wo man natürlich auch nochmal sagen muss, einer, der von Heidenheim kam, wo man, man hat sich auch beispielsweise bei Magdeburg sehr viel bedient. Also wirklich irgendwie auch gucken, okay, Leute, die die 2. Liga auch irgendwie kennen, aber gleichzeitig Potenzial sehen. Weil da ja auch so quasi, ja, kam eben von Saarbrücken. Also jetzt nicht so der Big Name Club in der 2. Liga in dem Sinne. Dass man da durchaus verstanden hat, wie das ineinandergreift, dass ich nicht immer die großen Ex-Spieler brauche, damit sowas funktioniert. Und da muss man, ich meine, man muss sagen, bei Paderborn war es wichtig, glaube ich, dass diese zwei Monate Pause kam, weil sie ja zum Ende der Hinrunde durchaus ordentlich Federn gelassen hat, wo man auch gesagt hat, okay, wenn sie oben dran bleiben müssen, dann muss jetzt auch so eine Serie her. In der 2. Liga schaffst du Dinge eh nur durch Serien. Da ist ein Ergebnis, vielleicht mal isoliert betrachtet, hatte ich mal bei einem Spieltag drei Plätze nach oben gebracht, wenn du aber die Woche drauf wieder verlierst und nicht herum den Team gewinnst. Im Abstiegskampf bist du so schnell da unten wieder komplett drin, was ganz viele Vereine gerade auch sehen. Und desto wichtiger ist es, dass du eben so eine Serie wie Paderborn aufbaust. Das kann eng sein wie gegen Karlsruhe, dieses ganz späte Tor, wie gegen Kaiserslautern dann auch irgendwann so ein bisschen erzwungen. Aber das kann eben auch sehr, sehr solide sein gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf, wo es natürlich auch unfassbar wichtig ist. Jemand, der in diesem Mix mit drin ist, dann auch wirklich in Schach zu halten und deutlich in seine Schranken zu weisen. Und ich meine, dieses Hannover-Spiel war einfach nur Vogelwild. Das ist halt das, was Paderborn auch in der Bundesliga immer damals auch unter Baum gart. Ich glaube, wir haben alle irgendwie noch das Spiel gegen Dortmund oder so im Kopf. Das ist ja das, woran ich immer denke, wenn man an Paderborn in der Bundesliga denkt. Aber das zeichnet die halt aus. Und es macht halt einfach als neutraler, neutrale Zuschauer in Spaß, den irgendwie zuzugucken. Also gerade, was da vorne geht, mit einem Piringer, mit einem Leiparz, mit einem Muslia, wieder Lücken gefunden werden im Spiel. Das ist schon sehr, sehr attraktiver Fußball dann auch.
Dann hacke ich noch mal kurz ein. Ich kann mich auch an das Spiel der Lilien in Paderborn erinnern. Anfang Oktober müsste das gewesen sein. Paderborn hat begonnen wie vom anderen Sternen. Schnelle Führung, dann noch vor der 10. Minute, 11 Meter, den dann Piringer verschossen hat. Dann gab es nach 15 Minuten einen Ausgleich. Dann war Paderborn beruhigt. Das fand ich erstaunlich, dass Darnstadt das mit einem ersten Angriff geregelt hat und das Spiel dann mit in den Griff bekommen hat. Noch Paderborn hat das Potenzial, eine Wucht zu entfalten wie Heidenheim, aber eben noch eine Mühe drüber. Im Endeffekt dürfen die Teams, die jetzt vorne drin stehen, wirklich dankbar sein, dass die so eine Blackout-Phase hatten zwischen dieser Länderspielphase, die du erwähnt hast, vorhin Eva und eben der Winterpause. Da hatten sie in fünf Spielen nur einen Punkt. Das ist für mich heute noch unerklärlich, wie das passieren konnte, weil die waren damals schon auf einem richtig guten Weg. Und dann sich gegen HSV Heidenheim, Bielefeld und Nürnberg Niederlagen abzuholen, ist bei HSV und Heidenheim nicht außergewöhnlich. Bei Bielefeld schon ein bisschen mehr, bei Nürnberg vielleicht auch. Aber das überrascht mich im Endeffekt mehr, als dass sie jetzt wieder in die Spur finden.
Nochmal der Vollständigkeit halber, auch weil du es schon gesagt hast, Eva Humphries. Das ist Basheer Humphries, ein Engländer, 19 Jahre jung, gerade erst Innenverteidiger von Chelsea's U21 gekommen. Der hat auch schon gegen Düsseldorf und Hannover die volle Distanz gespielt. Außerdem haben sie noch Niklas Natsch verpflichtet, 22 offensives Mittelfeld, vom SC Weiche, auch in der St. Pauli-Jugend. Und ein paar Statistiken auch noch mit dazu. Wir haben ja schon gesprochen über die vielen Tore, die sie schießen, sind auch die meisten 45. Danach kommt Heidenheim mit 43. Und danach erst der HSV, Kiel und dann auch erst Darmstadt und der Tabellenführer, also alles ganz interessant. Und im Schnitt haben sie auch den meisten Ballbesitz mit 59 Prozent und dem HSV zusammen. Also am Wochenende geht es gegen Kiel, dann gegen St. Pauli, danach gegen Magdeburg. Und wenn wir mal ehrlich sind, das sind schon alles Spiele, die ebenfalls gewonnen werden sollten. Und wer weiß, wenn dann so eine Serie dann eben noch so viele Spiele weitergeht, wo wir sie dann finden werden und was bei Heidenheim passiert, wie die sich da zusammen raufen. Dann überspringen wir mal ein paar Plätze und schauen auf Hannover 96. Die sind neunte. Die waren aber vor der Pause ja noch fünfter und sind dann abgerutscht auf den neunten. Und das zeigt dir auch wieder genau das, Eva, was du auch gesagt hattest, eben eine Serie etablieren. Oder wenn du mal so eine negativ Serie reinrutschst, dann geht das so, so schnell. Und das, finde ich, macht es auch wirklich, wirklich schwierig, so einzelne Ergebnisse zu analysieren oder zu sagen, okay, wenn jetzt in dem Spiel das passiert, dann passiert XYZ oder so. Das kann man halt einfach nicht sagen. Man muss immer irgendwie mit Serien rechnen und planen, weil das alles so eng ist. Hannover ist jetzt eben gestartet in dieses neue Jahr mit einer Niederlage gegen Lautern, Niederlage gegen St. Pauli, Niederlage gegen Paderborn und ein Unentschieden jetzt immerhin mal gegen Regensburg, dieses 1 zu 1. Tanja, ich weiß nicht, wie geht es dir dabei, wenn du Hannover irgendwie beobachtest? Was ist da passiert?
Ich glaube, das größte Problem von Hannover ist einfach die Inkonstanz. Die Mannschaft findet sich im Augenblick noch. Die haben vor der Saison einen neuen Trainer gekriegt. Die haben auch sehr viele neue Spieler dazugeholt. Das hat jetzt in der Hinrunde ganz gut hingehauen. Und jetzt ist halt so eine Phase. Also schon die Niederlage gegen Lautern hat den Hannoveranern wehgetan. Und dann auch noch bei Pauli zu verlieren war dann auch nicht so ganz schick. Und dann halt dieses absolut wilde Spiel gegen Paderborn, wo dann auch hinterher Leitll sich hinstellt und die Spieler anzählt, weil er da extrem unzufrieden war vor allen Dingen mit der Defensivleistung, was man nachvollziehen kann bei vier Gegentoren. Aber da ist dann halt sofort jetzt so ein bisschen Unruhe mit drin. Und da müssen sie halt die Konstanz irgendwie wiederfinden, die sie auch in der Hinrunde ja durchaus dann ausgezeichnet haben, dass sie dann Dinge eher ruhiger runterspielen konnten, als sie das jetzt zuletzt getan haben.
Du hast es gesagt, auf die Hinrunde hast du ein bisschen angespielt. Da hatten sie mal eine Strecke von sechs Spielen ohne Niederlage, und fünf davon waren Siege. Also das war auf jeden Fall ein anderer Schnack in der Hinrunde als jetzt im Vergleich zur Rückrunde. Eva, hatte ich das richtig gesehen, dass du gerade etwas sagen wolltest?
Ja, ich muss halt irgendwie dazu sagen, dass Hannover –also klar kann man nicht bestreiten, wo sie am Ende der Hinrunde standen. Aber ich habe dem Ganzen auch in der Hinrunde zum Teil nicht getraut, weil ich finde jetzt zum Teil, zum Beispiel im Vergleich zu Darmstadt, haben sie Spiele gewonnen und haben auch die zum Teil gewonnen in Partien, wo man sagt, okay, jetzt waren sie nicht unbedingt das bessere Team, und ist dann natürlich auch eine Qualität, da trotzdem zu gewinnen. Aber man hat also zwischendurch das Gefühl, naja, werden diese –also kommt da irgendwann dann mal noch ein richtiges System hinter, welche Spiele gewonnen werden, welche nicht, wo das hingeht. Und für mich ist halt immer noch so ein bisschen die Frage, wer ist jetzt der klare Zielspieler? Wo geht es jetzt irgendwie hin? Cedric Teuchert musste jetzt zuletzt immer mal wieder da gehen und einspringen. Also das Spiel gegen Regensburg würde ich aus einer Hannover-Perspektive schon fast als Frechheit bezeichnen, weil Regensburg und Hannover sind die vorm schwächsten Team der Liga momentan. Und wenn ich in diese Saison gehe und auch aus Leitelsicht irgendwie so ein bisschen anklingen lasse und die man möchte ja schon ganz gerne aufsteigen im ersten Jahr, wenn man hier ist, dann finde ich es auch ein bisschen bitter oder ein bisschen billig zu sagen, die diese Spieler dann anzukreiden nach dem 3-4. Gleichzeitig aber jetzt nach dem Regensburg-Spiel zu sagen, ne, die Spieler zeigen ja, dass sie es können, wo ich mir so denke, naja, also…
Was denn jetzt?
Irgendwie war das jetzt keine Verbesserung für mich, was ich da auf dem Platz gesehen habe. Also ich meine, ich habe es jetzt nicht über 90 Minuten gesehen, aber das, was ich davon gesehen habe, war defensiv wieder nicht gut. Also du hattest diesmal, du hast viel zu viele individuelle Fehler in dem Spiel drin. Es war Burner gegen Paderborn, zweimal eigentlich. Jetzt hattest du Ariane B. Gut, das ist noch ein relativ junger Spieler, aber wo man sich auch fragt, warum hilft ihm da auch keiner in der Situation, wo Singh dann das Tor erzielt. Defensiv sind da so viele Fragezeichen. Das war bei Hannover letzte Saison genauso. Das ist etwas, wo ich keine Entwicklung sehe. Natürlich war da ein Trainerwechsel dazwischen. Aber wo ich mich tatsächlich ein bisschen frage, wie ich überhaupt auf die Idee kommen kann, vor dieser Saison so einen Anspruch zu stellen, wo man noch nichts von dem Trainer gesehen hat. Natürlich hat Leitllinien zum Ausstieg geführt. Aber das ging ja auch nicht von heute auf morgen. Und klar, ich gucke Maximilian Bayer unfassbar gerne beim Fußballspielen zu. Aber da ist auch eine Verantwortung auf einen jungen Spieler wie Bayer, was ich nicht verstehe. Du hast Berner, der jetzt auch auswählt. Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, wo die Achse ist in diesem Team.
Ja, Hannover ist für mich wirklich auch ein großes Rätsel. Auf mich wirkt es so, als ob die Summe der Einzelspieler nicht mal die Endsumme des Teams ergibt. Die Underperformen gewaltig. Ich habe es auch so im Ohren vor der Saison so verstanden, dass die schon angreifen wollen. Dafür war die Vorrunde jetzt okay, aber auch nicht mehr. Jetzt in der Winterpause dann schon noch mal für mich Signale auszusenden. Jetzt holen wir aber auf und dann so zu starten, ist schon wirklich krass. Ich hatte das Spiel gegen Kaislautern verfolgt. Da führten sie zur Halbzeit 1-0. Dann lassen sie sich noch mal drei Tore einschenken. Das war für mich vollkommen verdient, der Sieg von Kaislautern damals. Da muss ich mir schon auch fragen, was da nicht so ganz funktioniert. Auch nach vorne ist es nicht sonderlich schlagkräftig. Ich glaube, die haben eine der eher wenigen Chancen. Mit 102 oder was habe ich im Klicker gelesen, das ist im Vergleich zu den Spitzen-Teams nicht wirklich vorweisbar. Demzufolge glaube ich schon, dass da dieses Jahr so ein Findungsprozess stattfinden muss. Wenn sie sich nächstes Jahr ein bisschen gesetzt haben, dann darf da was gehen. Aber da der Abstand nach vorne jetzt schon gewaltig ist, glaube ich, müssen sie sich umorientieren.
Ich finde es auch eben so interessant, dass ich glaube am 13. Februar hatte ich noch im Klicker gelesen und das war eben nach der Niederlage gegen Paderborn. Wo die Frage in den Raum gestellt wurde, war es das in Sachen Aufstieg? Und jetzt muss man sich wirklich schon mehr nach unten orientieren und gucken, dass man da nicht mit reinrutscht. Ich finde es auch –Eva-Lotta hast das vollkommen richtig gesagt –absurd, dass man so jungen Spielern so viel aufbürdet. Auch so ein R&B, der ja auch gerade erst 19 Jahre alt ist und der da nicht so unterstützt wird. Was genau das widerspiegelt, Matthias, was du gesagt hast, dass eben nicht mal die Summe der Einzelteile scheint da auf dem Platz zu stehen. Alles sehr, sehr schwierig. Bei Hannover mal gucken, ob sie da weiter mit runterrasseln.
Definitiv. Ich glaube, dann noch einen Einwurf. Dann können wir es auch abbinden. Bei dem Tor jetzt in Regensburg, das war doch, glaube ich, durch Teuchert dieser Distanzschuss, wo dann er auch ansatzweise auf die Fernkurve zugeht und die Arme ausstreckt. Dann denke ich mir so, es war da nicht einzusehen in den Highlights, was die Fans dazu sagen. Aber da würde ich mir glaube ich echt verarscht vorkommen, wenn ich sehe, dass ich mich gegen einen Regensburg in der Form, die ja davor in Nürnberg auch nicht gerade überperformt haben, zu einem unschieden Rätsel und dann ja so signalisiere, hey, war ein schönes Tor, oder?
Auf der anderen Seite könnte das ja auch heißen, dass die Spieler selber wissen, wo sie flehen und eben das schon angenommen haben, hey, wir können uns darüber freuen, dass wir das 1 zu 1 noch gemacht haben überhaupt. Jetzt am Wochenende, wie gesagt, geht es weiter gegen Magdeburg. Das dürfte auch auf jeden Fall ein wichtiges Spiel sein, dass wir da von unten ein bisschen wegbleiben. Dann geht es nach Fürth und dann gegen Rostock. Und dann würde ich mal sagen, kommen wir zu unserer ersten Trainerentlassung hier und springen wieder ein paar Plätze auf dem 13. zu Nürnberg. Das war, wie gesagt, eine von den Trainerentlassungen. Markus Weinziel entlassen, wo ich auch ehrlich gestehen muss, dass ich mich nie so richtig damit abfinden konnte. Das hat sich nicht richtig angefühlt, Markus Weinziel beim 1. FC Nürnberg zu sehen. Jetzt übernimmt Dieter Hecking, der ja auch Sportvorstand ist. War Trainer zuletzt 2019 bis 2020 beim HSV. Also Tanja, du erinnerst dich da vielleicht noch am allerbesten an. Was können wir uns da jetzt erwarten? Wieso kommt der Trainerwechsel jetzt? Und wieso fällt die Wahl auf Hecking?
Warum die Wahl jetzt gerade auf Hecking fällt? Ich glaube, ihm ist nichts Besseres mehr eingefallen. Sie haben ja auch schon den Wechsel von Klaus zu Weinziel weitergemacht. Ich habe irgendwas gelesen, dass Hecking Weinziel auch durchaus massive Vorwürfe gemacht hat, dass er falsch aufgestellt hat und das System nicht so richtig durchschaut hat. Dann macht er das halt selber. Ich bin im Nachhinein sehr froh, dass unser Sportvorstand keine A-Lizenz hat oder keine Trainerlizenz. Das weiß ich nicht. Ich finde das immer etwas schwierig, wenn der Sportvorstand sich dann auf die Bank setzt. Aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass Dieter Hecking da ein bisschen mehr Struktur reinbringt, weil offensichtlich von seinem Kader ist er ja überzeugt.
Da muss man glaube ich tatsächlich aber einhaken, dass es, glaube ich, auch keine komplett freiwillige Entscheidung von Hecking ist. Das große Problem, was der SRFC Nürnberg hat, ist, dass das Geld fehlt. Also Nürnberg ist ja einer dieser Vereine, der auch von Diana Strafe betroffen ist und die ja, wenn man das mal zwischen den Zeilen liest, ja auch tatsächlich noch einen Punkteabzug erwarten. Also warum ja auch man überhaupt, glaube ich, damals von Klaus zu Weinziel gewechselt ist, was ich von Anfang an auch nochmal sagen muss. Weinziel ist dann nicht der erste Trainer, der mir einfällt, der glaube ich auf der Payroll so unfassbar günstig ist. Einfach durch die Erfahrung, die er jetzt, wie er erfolgreich auch immer mitbringt. Er hat einfach unfassbar viele Bundesliga-Jahre hinter sich. Das ist halt nicht so der, sag ich jetzt mal günstigste Trainer, den du dann in dem Moment bekommen kannst. Und ich meine, man hat im Endeffekt dreimal unter ihm in der Liga gewonnen, halt die zwei Pokalspiele. Und es war gegen Düsseldorf. Ich meine, man muss halt dazu sagen, zwei davon gingen eher Aufstiegskandidaten mit Düsseldorf und Paderborn. Aber wir haben eben schon darüber gesprochen, dass dieser Sieg gegen Paderborn in seine Zeit fiel. Also man würde das wahrscheinlich eher noch auf Paderborn schieben als wie gut Nürnberg war. Und das, also Hacking ist halt so dermaßen jetzt im Kreuzfeuer, weil er hat den Kader zusammengestellt. Ich muss immer noch sagen, es geht nicht in meinen Kopf rein, wie man auf die Idee kommen kann, Manuel Winzheimer an einen direkten Ligakonkurrenten zu verleihen. Also erstens bekomme ich dadurch kein Geld rein. Ja, dann guck halt, also so blöd wie es klingt, aber verscherbel den irgendwie nach England oder so. Die zahlen dann immer noch genug Geld im Zweifel. Aber ich mache ja nur ein Minusgeschäft, weil Winzheimer ist jetzt bei meinem direkten Konkurrenten da unten drin und schießt halt die Tore unter anderem. Oder gibt die Assists und ich stehe da und hole mir einen Damien Blum, der sowieso schon eine unfassbare Verletzungshistorie hat und natürlich verletzt er sich und ist raus. Das heißt, ich stehe nicht noch genauso da wie vor der Winterpause. Ich stehe sogar noch schlechter aus, wenn wir meiner Option nach vorne hinausgegangen sind, ich kein Geld habe, um irgendwas daran zu hänkeln. Und der, der dafür verantwortlich ist, steht jetzt auch noch an der Seitenlinie. Also ich weiß nicht und ich meine, da muss man ja natürlich auch sagen, kriege ich mit einem Sportgeschäftsführer als Spieler ein anderes Gespräch als mit dem Trainer. Also was auch eine Erwartungshaltung, weil man weiß ja, im Zweifel ist ja immer als Erstes der Trainer weg, bevor irgendwelche Spieler weggegeben werden. Und Nürnberg-Spieler waren furchtbar mit anzusehen diese Saison. Also die schießen ja auch einfach irgendwie keine Tore. Nach vorne ist es so dünn. Und dann auch noch –ich sage es nochmal –eine Offensivkraft wegzugeben, die ich vor dieser Saison gerade erst geholt habe. Es geht nicht in meinen Kopf rein. Keine Ahnung. Also klar, hat Weinziel dann –ich glaube, dass es jetzt nicht so ungewöhnlich ist, dass er vielleicht nicht früher gehen könnte. Für mich ist dann immer die Frage, ich hatte gerade zwei Monate Pause. Was hätte Weinziel in diesen vier Spielen veranstalten sollen, nachdem er ja ein Spiel gewonnen hat und sie im Pokal auch weitergekommen sind? King von Dona Düsseldorf –das habe ich mich auch vorgefragt.
Warum jetzt dieser Zeitpunkt?
Ja, also in der Retrospective wirkt das alles wirklich merkwürdig. Ich meine, auf Klaus ein Weinziel zu holen, ist auch, glaube ich, schon von der Spielanlage her schwierig. Und wenn ich als Hacking über einige Transferperioden hinweg die Möglichkeit habe, den Kader auszurichten, dann stelle ich mir ja was vor, was Klaus damit anfangen soll und dann hole ich Weinziel. Also das ist wirklich sehr irritierend. Und dieses offensive Trauerspiel ist ja von Eva gerade angeklungen. Das ist tatsächlich auffällig. Und ich meine sogar, dass vor dem Spiel in Heidenheim Weinziel von der Sky-Moderatorin noch gefragt wurde, wie er dann die Strafraumphobie gedenkt zu beheben, weil sie wohl seit ewigen Zeiten schon keinen Tor mehr aus dem Strafraum heraus erzielt haben. Und da kamen eigentlich eher ein paar Platitüden. Aber es zeigt halt auch, dass da der Ansatz im Moment irgendwie schwieriger ist. Und da muss ich schon sagen, Glück auf, Dieter Häckling, keine Ahnung. Da fehlen mir gerade auch so ein paar Ansatzpunkte, wie das sich noch in ein angenehmeres Fahrwasser begeben soll.
Die wenigsten Tore der Liga haben sie tatsächlich erzielt, 17 nur.
Obwohl sie so jemand wie Möller Deli im Kader haben, der ja durchaus auch entstanden ist, eine Chance zu kreieren.
Der ist gerade in seinem richtigen Loch drin.
Ja, die Frage ist ja auch, Torchancen für wen kreieren. Also es tut mir leid, Quattro Trua bringt halt Schnelligkeit mit, hat auch das eine oder andere Tor geschossen, aber er ist definitiv wahrscheinlich nicht so der Zielspieler. Mir fehlt halt, dann muss man Valentini wieder in die Rolle schlüpfen, der vorher eineinhalb Jahre nicht getroffen hat, fliegt dann aber am nächsten Spiel vom Platz für einen Spieler wie Valentini, Summela, dass wir das so sagen müssen, aber Naivität in dieses –also es war halt wirklich, was man ja eigentlich Frustfaul nennt. Ja, aber irgendwie, also man hatte dann, mir tut es auch so jemanden leid wie Winderl, den Teuter, den sie auch verpflichten mussten, weil Martenia verletzt ist, aber auch diese Innenverteidigung. Ich hab einen Jamara, den Tanja bestimmt auch noch sozia beim HSV kennt. Ich hab irgendwie Hübner und Kastrop und da waren Abwehrfehler dabei gegen Heidenheim. Also ich meine, klar kann man gegen Heidenheim verlieren, aber ob man jetzt den roten Teppich im Strafraum ausrollen muss, das ist halt eine andere Frage und das hat für mich dann noch nichts mehr mit System zu tun. Also davon abgesehen, dass ich nicht verstehe, warum Weinzie durchgängig mit dem 4-4-2, mit Doppel-6 gespielt hat, weil es irgendwann halt die Offensive überhaupt nicht anbietet. Aber ja, weiß ich nicht.
Also jeder von den Hörerinnen darf sich ermuntert fühlen, mal die Kicker-App aufzurufen und bei Nürnberg den Kader durchzugehen. Man wird bei kaum einem Zweite-Legisten mehr Spiele unter Sturm aufgelistet sehen. Da sind sicherlich auch junge Spieler mit dabei. Aber es ist ja irgendwie auch eine Unwucht. Und dafür kommt vielleicht wenig bei rum. Und die Verletzten klangen gerade schon an, auch in der Verteidigung. Also da ist natürlich wirklich ein bisschen Bluten müssen. Nicht nur in Martenia, auch mit Handwerker und Wegesser. Und dann der nachverpflichtete Horn, der kommt auch sich nochmal verletzt.
Das ist natürlich Pech, aber alles in allem …Ich finde das auch irgendwie total interessant, dass es ja sowieso schon die Kritik gab, dass der Kader viel zu groß wäre. Und dann holen sie jetzt in der Wintertransferphase auch nochmal wahnsinnig viele neue Leute. Also müssen sie irgendwie auch wegen verletzten. Aber dann haben wir Dani Blum, Benjamin Goller, den ich eigentlich auch für einen sehr guten Fußballer halte. Florian Flick von Schalke ausgeliehen, Janis Horn von Bochum ausgeliehen, Gustavo Puerta von Leverkusen ausgeliehen. Das sind natürlich auch viele Lien. Dann haben wir noch Jermaine Nischalke, Peter Winder-Jensen eben. Und dagegen nur einen Abgang. Aber der dann eben Manuel Winzheimer ist. Anderen direkten Kollegen. Also auch hier ein riesengroßes Fragezeichen. Habt ihr noch unbedingt was, was ihr loswerden wollt zu Nürnberg? Oder wollen wir weitergehen?
Nee, also ganz kurz so mal. Aber noch mal, der dafür verantwortlich ist, steht jetzt an der Seitenlinie. Ich weiß halt als Nürnberg-Fan nicht, wie ich darüber fühlen sollte.
Ist halt seine große Chance vielleicht auch alle irgendwie, um sie falsch zu beweisen?
Ja, aber auch dann hat er ja nicht die Trainer verpflichtet, die mit zu den Spielern passen und vice versa. Also alles, egal wie es jetzt läuft, das ist eine absolute Loose-Loose-Situation für Dieter Hecking.
Ja, aber wie wir festgestellt haben, der Kader ist ja groß genug, um eigentlich alle Systeme zu spielen.
Vielleicht war das sein ultimativer Plan. Was ich ganz witzig finde, ist, dass es jetzt am Wochenende für Nürnberg, also mit Dieter Hecking, an der Seitenlinie gegen Sandhausen geht. Die haben ja auch gerade ihren Trainer entlassen. Als Hecking noch Trainer beim HSV war, ist er damals geflogen nach dem 1-5-Debakel gegen Sandhausen. Da ist also eine Rechnung offen und irgendwie passt alles so zusammen. Das ist irgendwie ganz witzig. Danach, nach Sandhausen, kommt aber eben auch schon der HSV. Danach Braunschweig gegen Winzheimer. Das sind alles irgendwie Spiele, die nicht so ohne sind, sagen wir es mal so. Dann springen wir mal weiter zu Magdeburg, die ja eigentlich ganz gut gestartet waren, sind jetzt auch so über den Strich gerutscht. Gerade so ist ja wirklich alles noch mal irre knapp da unten. Sie sind jetzt aktuell punktgleich mit Braunschweig. Ein Punkt hinter Nürnberg eben. Und die sind auch, ja, ich weiß nicht, für Magdeburg eigentlich ziemlich okay gestartet, würde ich fast sagen. Also eine Niederlage, zwei Niederlagen, ein Unentschieden und ein Sieg gegen Kiel eben. Jetzt zuletzt diese zweite Niederlage eben gegen St. Pauli 1 zu 2. Haben drei Neuzugänge in der Winter-Transferphase noch verzeichnet. Daniel Heber von Rot-Weiß Essen, Maximilian Ullmann von Venezia aus der Serie B ausgeliehen auch. Und Luke Castañas. Ein Abgang. Ömer Bey ist jetzt nach Stuttgart gegangen. Wie findet ihr das so? Wie findet ihr diesen Restart, wenn man es so sagen will, nach der Winterpause von Magdeburg? Was haltet ihr von diesen vier Spielen? Matthias vielleicht?
Da bin ich jetzt fast auf dem falschen Fuß. Ich finde, du hast die Neuverpflichtungen angesprochen, die jetzt zur Winterpause kamen. Sie hatten ja auch schon im Verlauf der Vorrunde nachjustiert. Also Piccini kam, glaube ich, nach dem Saisonbeginn. Ist ein richtig guter auf seiner Position in der Verteidigung. Bochon, glaube ich, kam auch erst nach Saisonbeginn. Der hatte ja in Bochum durchaus auch auf sich aufmerksam gemacht, hat eine Schnelligkeit. Also das zeigte mir, dass Magdeburg schon früh ein paar Zeichen erkannt hat, wo es nochmal nachzujustieren gilt. Und ich finde, die Spiele nach wie vor für einen Aufsteiger sind sich treu geblieben, haben in der 3. Liga schon spielerisch überzeugt. Baris Atik natürlich in erster Linie auf sich aufmerksam gemacht und zumindest bis zum Darmstadt-Spiel haben sie diesen Plan nachverfolgt und sind ihm treu geblieben. Das finde ich wiederum sehr zu begrüßen, dass jemand hinter seinem System steht und dem vertraut und dann noch Spieler hinzuaddiert, die eventuell dann passen könnten. Natürlich sind sie viel zu heimschwache. Ich glaube, 8 Punkte nur zu Hause, das ist natürlich, gerade bei so einem stimmungsvollen Publikum, ja irgendwie auch fast verwunderlich, dass das nicht so ganz aufgeht. Und da muss schon schleunigst ein bisschen mehr bei rumkommen, um die Klasse dann auch schlussendlich zu halten. Ich hoffe auf jeden Fall, dass sie sich trauen, an Tits festzuhalten. Weil dann, ich habe auch die gegen Darmstadt ganz gut gesehen. Die haben dann eben von diesem dämlichen Platz verweist, der für mich keiner war, eben nicht profitiert, sondern der fuhr ihnen in die Parade. Davor war das sehr gefährlich, was die gemacht haben, und auch zu Abschlüssen gekommen. Deshalb will ich hoffen, dass sie vielleicht noch ein bisschen in ihrer Lehre ziehen, aber rechtzeitig die Lehre ziehen, um dann die Kurve zu kriegen oder eben nicht ganz unten reingesogen zu werden. Die zweite Tabellenhälfte ist verdammt eng. Also reicht schon ein Spieltag, um sich auf dem letzten Platz wieder zu finden. Deshalb ja mein Plädoyer und meine Hoffnung, dass das fruchtet, was da so angelegt ist.
Ich finde es auch ganz unabhängig von den anderen Teams, die da unten drin stehen, aber Magdeburg, den würde ich auch irgendwie echt wünschen, dass sie so noch mit drin bleiben in der zweiten Liga, weil ich finde, es macht auch echt Spaß, den so zuzugucken. Und irgendwie finde ich es schön, wenn sie sich ja etablieren können. Baris Atek, muss ich auch nochmal sagen, dieser Distanztreffer gegen St. Pauli zum 1 zu 0. Also sehr schön, bin ein großer Fan von. Eva, ich weiß nicht, hatte ich das richtig gesehen, dass du was sagen wolltest auch oder?
Ja, ich finde halt bei Magdeburg das größte Problem ist, dass die sich selber im Weg stehen. Also, ich meine, wenn wir uns jetzt irgendwie mal so vielleicht mehr als nur die letzten, also die vier Spiele in 2023, ich meine, ich habe sie ja natürlich auch gegen Bielefeld gesehen. Matthias, du hast das Spiel gerade gegen Darmstadt erwähnt. Auch im Spiel gegen Bielefeld. Die waren eigentlich so schlecht. Also, die hatten, glaube ich, auch mehr Schüsse aus Tor, waren offensiv, auch nicht unattraktiv. Aber, also, und gegen Aminia Bielefeld zu diesem Zeitpunkt, 3-1 zu verlieren, gegen einen Mitkandidaten da unten, gegen einen Abstieg und dem halt wirklich mehr oder weniger den Sieg zu schenken, weil man viel zu einfache Fehler macht, weil man zum Teil nicht rausrückt, weil man irgendwie einen Spiel auch irgendwann verschenkt. Also das fand ich so krass zuletzt gegen St. Pauli. Es gibt wenig, was man bei St. Pauli nicht macht. Also gegen St. Pauli sollte man eine Sache vor allem nicht machen, und das ist bei Standards nicht vernünftig aufpassen. Weil man weiß immer gerade durch Lea Pakarada, der ist in, sagen wir mal, acht von zehn Spielen sehr, sehr gut drauf, auch wenn der Rest jetzt Teamnissing macht und dann steht halt irgendwie Jackson Eulwaer, dass auch nicht zum ersten Mal diese Saison passiert ist. Komplett frei im 16er kann da einnicken und dann denkst du dir, ja okay, geht es halt 1-1 aus. Und dann aber irgendwie dann nochmal pseudomäßig auf Abseits zu stellen in dieser Szene mit Medici. Ich meine, das war ein super Ball von Hardel, glaube ich. Aber dann irgendwie da noch mal dieses Gegentor zu fangen, das meine ich mit, die stehen sich halt selber auf den Füßen irgendwie. Ich finde auch den Heber, Daniel Heber war eine unfassbar gute Ergänzung. Der hat, glaube ich, gegen Düsseldorf dreimal irgendwie auf der Linie geklärt. Du hast mit El-Fadli jemanden, der eigentlich in der Verteidigung spielt, aber durchaus auch jetzt irgendwie sein offensives Blut entdeckt hat. Aber auch das Spiel gegen Düsseldorf. Düsseldorf war nicht gut. Dieses Spiel war nicht gut. Und Magdeburg hätte da durchaus einen Punkt verdient gehabt. Aber sie stehen sich da irgendwie selber auch im Weg. Und es gibt irgendwie Flipper-Tore hier und da. Und man verschenkt die letzten 15 Minuten. Man hört einfach auf, Fußball zu spielen, lässt Düsseldorf rankommen, irgendwie gefühlt 20 Torschüsse noch abgeben. Und dann kommt natürlich dazu –und ich glaube, viele von uns haben es irgendwie gesehen –nach diesem 1-1 gegen Karlsruhe, du denkst, ey, Magdeburg ist immer noch Aufsteiger. Die haben vor der Saison die Hälfte ihres Karlsruhes an Paderborn verloren gefühlt. Spielen da 1-1, all good. Und dann gibt es irgendwie diese Ansprache der Fans, wo man die Leistung kritisiert. Und dann gewinnt man die Woche drauf gegen Kiel, wo man aber nochmal sagen muss, warum weiß niemand, weil Kiel darf dieses Spiel in tausend Jahren nicht verlieren, wo ich mir denke, was mache ich damit? Gut, nutze ich die ganze Stunde, muss ich gegen einen sehr, sehr guten St. Pauli, die extrem gut in das neue Jahr unter Hürzler gestartet sind, reingehen, spiele vielleicht 45 Minuten Fußball und höre dann aber auch auf, wo ich mir als Fans denke, da muss ich tatsächlich mal sagen, nicht nur wirklich auf die Ergebnisse gucken, sondern was wird leistungstechnisch geboten, und das darf sich Magdeburg erlauben, im Gegensatz zu, ich weiß jetzt im Hannover 96, wo man sagen muss, wir haben zumindest noch 1-1 gespielt, da steht eine Mannschaft auf dem Platz, wo ich mich dann frage, irgendwie passt es dann für mich auch erwartungshaltungstechnisch, der Fans nicht zusammen, ich möchte niemanden nicht Fans reinreden, wie sie mit ihrer Mannschaft umzugehen haben, aber es hat mich schon stark verwundert irgendwie, weil ich das einfach das falsche Zeichen zu diesem Zeitpunkt finde. Gerade wenn du zu Hause absolute Probleme hast, ich habe es angesprochen, weiß ich nicht, ob das der richtige Weg ist, und indirekt hast du ja gegen St. Pauli gesehen, geholfen hat es nicht, zu Hause da dann irgendwie zu bestehen.
Ich muss aber auch noch mal kurz dazu sagen, ich kenne ja Christian Titz jetzt auch schon als HSV-Trainer, wir reden ja auch nicht, das waren ja alle irgendwann mal bei uns. Ich mag den total gerne, der ist zwar mit uns abgestiegen, aber er hat sozusagen das Volksparkstadion gerettet, weil durch seine positive Art ist der Abstieg halt nicht so komplett in die Binsen gegangen. Aber sein Spielsystem ist halt extrem offensiv und defensiv kann er nicht. Das sieht man jetzt halt auch bei Magdeburg. Als Aufsteiger ist das echt gefährlich, was er da spielen lässt.
Macht halt Spaß, aber ist gefährlich, absolut. Am Wochenende geht es jetzt gegen Hannover. Das wird ein sehr, sehr wichtiges Spiel, aber ich glaube trotzdem auch, gegen wen, wenn nicht gegen Hannover aktuell, da irgendwie mal ein paar Punkte holen. Danach jetzt gegen Lautern und Paderborn. Alles nicht so einfach. Da ist also auch nochmal ordentlich Gefahr da, dass es auch nochmal ganz tief runtergeht. So sah es ja eben auch bei Regensburg aus, wenn wir jetzt mal weitergehen und die Arminia überspringen. Weil, wenn wir mal ganz ehrlich sind, da ist schon eigentlich genug gesagt und viel mehr Neues außer Frust, sage ich mal. Da kommen wir wahrscheinlich nicht sehr weit bei rum. Bei Regensburg finde ich es sehr schön, sich bei Transfermarkt mal diesen Grafen anzugucken, wie der Verlauf der Tabellenverlauf aussieht. Das ist eine sehr schöne Kurve. Erst so ein bisschen nach oben und dann sehr rund nach unten und jetzt wieder nach oben. So ein kleines bisschen der Ausflug ans Tabellenende als Schlusslicht war wirklich nur sehr kurz. Auch weil es da noch ein anderes Team gibt, dass da noch schlechter am Start ist. Die letzten vier Spiele im neuen Jahr waren auch nicht gut. Drei Niederlagen, ein Unentschieden, dieses Unentschieden 1 zu 1 gegen Hannover davor, gegen Nürnberg, Bielefeld und Darmstadt verloren. Das sieht, wie gesagt, echt nicht gut aus. Gemeinsam mit Aminia ein Punkt hinter Magdeburg und Braunschweig. Die Passquote, das fand ich auch sehr bezeichnend. Wenn wir mal mit den Statistiken losgehen, liegt im Schnitt bei rund 76 Prozent. Das sind 75,6 Prozent, glaube ich. Das ist ein drittschlechteste. Das sieht man auch sehr gut auf dem Platz. Matthias, deine Lilien haben ja eben dieses Auftaktspiel nach der Winterpause gegen Regensburg gemacht. Wieso sind die noch mal so krass abgestürzt? Die waren ja davor, vor dieser Winterpause, noch nicht so tief drin.
Sie haben auch am Anfang den Eindruck erweckt, als hätten sie einen Plan. Sie sind schon ziemlich gallig rangegangen. Das kennt man eigentlich als Gegner von Regensburgern Teams, dass die schon eine gewisse Körperlichkeit auf den Platz bringen und damit auch schnell mal anderen Teams den Schneid abkaufen. So ist zumindest bei mir Regensburg gerne mal in der Schublade. Die ersten zehn Minuten sahen auch wirklich gut aus, aber dann haben sie sich durch zwei Fehler aus dem Spiel genommen. Einmal haben sie einen neuen Torwart, ihr junger Torwart, Keeper Jonas Urwig aus Köln, dem sie gleich das Vertrauen geschenkt haben. Der ist quasi zwischen die Pfosten gewandert, spielt zentral raus. Ich glaube, ich komme jetzt gerade nicht darauf, wer den Fehler gemacht hat. Auf jeden Fall wollte der Ballabnehmer dann irgendwie einen Lillenspieler stehen lassen, aber das war eine denkbar schlechte Idee. Mirlem ist dazwischen gegangen. Dann war es durch Manu 1-0 und dann noch ein Platzverweis durch Kennedy, glaube ich, wenig später. Das Spiel war damit schon die falschen Bahnen aus Regensburgers Sicht geleitet und dann durch einen 2-0 noch vor der Pause gegessen. Die zweite Halbzeit hätte man sich sparen können. Da war Regensburg sich selbst im Weg gestanden und hat es nicht geschafft –klein unterzahll ist es schwer –aber irgendwie noch Akzente zu setzen in dem Spiel. Das hat mich dann ein bisschen überrascht. Bei Regensburg hatte ich doch von der Mentalität anders kennengelernt. Im Kicker hatte ich zuletzt mal gelesen, die haben ihren Sportverstand damals nach Köln abgegeben vor mittlerweile 15, 16 Monaten, glaube ich. Seither ist die Punkt-Schnittquote von Regensburg gar nicht so gut, die sich um den einen Punkt oder sogar noch weniger herumgruppiert. Da wurde dann so ein bisschen hergeleitet, der Abgang tut schon weh, weil der war mehr als jemand, der in der Chefletage sitzt, sondern der schon auch für den Club viel beleuchtet hat. Regensburg ist ja kein großer Standort. Wie in Darmstadt auch, kennt man kurze Wege und spielt wahrscheinlich auch eine andere Rolle als jetzt beim VfB oder beim HSV oder bei sonst jemandem. Da wurde diese Personalie einfach erwähnt. Das fand ich dann in der Quote ganz interessant, dass das vom Punkt-Schnitt deutlich nach unten ging. Ich bin gespannt, wo es jetzt mit Ihnen weitergeht. Ich kann es jetzt nicht so sehr einordnen. Es ist jetzt für meine Begriffe kein unruhiger Standort. Ich glaube, da weiß man auch, welche Qualitäten man auf den Platz bringen muss. Gegen Nürnberg war es wohl sehr, sehr mau, was sie gezeigt haben. Da hingegen ging Hannover jetzt wieder in eine richtige Reaktion gezeigt. Sing kommt jetzt zurück, der vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen was spielerisches oder in kreativem Sinne, was Torchancen anbetrifft, beisteuern kann. Vielleicht fehlen Ihnen aber auch so Spieler, die in der Panne gekommen sind, wie ein Besuchkov, der in Regensburg schon eine gute Rolle gespielt hat. Oder auch Weckesser, der eine Wahnsinns-Physis reingebracht hat und auch schon Gegenspielern wehtun konnte, ohne jetzt überziehen zu müssen. Aber vielleicht sind es auch so ein paar kleine Schräubchen. Aber ich traue denen zu, so in gallischer Dorfmanier doch noch irgendwie da unten sich zu behaupten.
Wie gesagt, es ist ja auch super schwierig, einfach weil da alles so eng ist. Jonas Urbig, du hattest es gesagt von Köln ausgeliehen. Der ist gerade 19 Jahre alt und das finde ich auch super spannend. Von Stojanovic zu Kirchbaum zu Urbig, von 29 zu 35 zu 19. Irgendwie sehr spannend. Eva, du wolltest auch noch was sagen.
Ja, ich finde halt irgendwie bei Regensburg ist bei mir so ein bisschen das Problem, dass sie ja letztes Jahr auch gegen Ende der Saison durchaus noch da unten reingeraten sind. Und eigentlich damals nur wegen ihrer, glaube ich, sechs Spiele am Anfang der Saison, wo sie ja zwischenzeitlich auch an der Tabellenspitze standen, eben, man muss das glaube ich so sagen, nicht abgestiegen sind. Und was für mich halt eher das Problem war, ist, dass ich im Sommer keine richtige Reaktion darauf gesehen habe. Also ich fand eigentlich Stojanovic als Torhüter keine schlechte Wahl, weil Meier ja nun mal zu Borussia Dortmund gegangen ist. Hab ihn jetzt aber auch irgendwie schon wieder durch einen, wie schon gesagt, 19-Jährigen ersetzt, wo wir wieder über das Thema Druck bei jungen Spielern sprechen.
Sieben Gegentore in vier Spielen helfen da auch nicht unbedingt?
Nee, und dann hast du halt auch, weiß ich nicht, fehlt mir da auch irgendwie, da fehlen mir bis heute die klaren Ersatzspieler. Du hast jemanden wie Prinz Jose Owusu geholt, der glaube ich seine ersten Zweitliga-Tore jetzt mal bei Regensburg geschossen hat, der aber vorher bei Bielefeld und Paderborn nicht gerade Top Go-Getter geschrien hat. Also von außen, auch da der einzige, den ich vielleicht mal so ein bisschen positiver auch hervorheben würde, ist jemand wie, ja, Leute wie Jan Elvedi, die da im Defensivwerk so ein bisschen versuchen, die Dinge zu ordnen. Elvedi hat ja auch unter anderem gegen Bielefeld dann da sein erstes Tor geschossen, fast ein Doppelpack. Sabrit Singh ist halt wirklich für mich ein merkwürdiger Spieler. Ich meine, er sollte, glaube ich, ja auch zu Werder kommen, hat da den Medizintest nicht bestanden. Und jetzt sollte er von Bayerns Zweiter an –eigentlich ist er ja seit Anfang der Saison bei Regensburg –aber er durfte, hatte keine Spielberechtigung, weil irgendwelche Unterlagen vergessen wurden einzureichen. Wo man dann natürlich auch sagen muss, auch das geht dann Richtung Geschäftsführersport. Was du angesprochen hast, Nina, ist dann natürlich auch die Frage, hilft alles auch nicht, diese Position zu stärken? Natürlich mit Andreas Eivers, der jetzt sechs Tore hat, schreit jetzt auch nicht irgendwie. Ja, weiß ich nicht, Top-Go-Score auch hier.
Und der auch Hannover aus dem Spiel hätte nehmen können am Wochenende mit dem Elfmeter.
Ja, und dann ja eher noch dafür sorgt, dass Hannover überhaupt zurückkommt, weil er den Ball nicht vernünftig klärt. Und ich habe sie ja sogar live im Stadion gegen Bielefeld gesehen. Ich meine, man muss auch sagen, auch ein bisschen unglücklich da. Man könnte auch da über einen Elfmeter eventuell diskutieren gegen Mowusu, der dann ja auch jetzt erstmal raus ist, mit einer Kopfverletzung in die Richtung. Aber auch da hat man in der zweiten Hälfte Bielefeld so unnötig am Ende kommen lassen. Das war in der Verteidigung nicht zweitligereif. Also zweimal sich so ein Tor zu fangen, vor allem das zweite Tor von Klos, wo der ungefähr von der Strafraumkante diesen Ball reinköpfen kann, ohne dass irgendjemand dagegen was unternimmt, nach einem langen Ball, der von Huck auf eine andere Seite reinkommt. Das darf den nicht passieren. Und für mich ist es ehrlich gesagt fast eher überreif, dass Regensburg in diesem Abstiegskampf ist, weil sie eben letztes Jahr da schon waren. Da dachte man kurz am Anfang der Saison haben sie gegen Darmstadt gewonnen, sie haben gegen Bielefeld gewonnen, aber auch gerade gegen Bielefeld. Das war schon kein überzeugendes Spiel von ihnen. Da hat es halt einfach zu dem Zeitpunkt sowieso gereicht, wenn die Gegner von Bielefeld maximal mit 70 Prozent angereist sind. Aber für mich ist es ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht überraschend, dass sie da unten drin sind. Und ich frage mich, klar, wir freuen uns alle, wenn Mannschaften auch mal länger an einem Trainer festhalten. Aber bei Siljanović sehe ich halt genau die gleichen Mechanismen, die greifen wie letztes Jahr, wo ich mich dann halt frage, naja, also entweder ihr habt keine höhere Erwartungshaltung und sagt, da gehören wir halt irgendwie hin, den Abschießkampf der 2. Liga. Oder ich muss halt irgendwann mal sagen, sind wir ehrlich? Wir nehmen seit einem Jahr keinerlei Entwicklung in dem Sinne. Wir müssen wirklich sagen, das sind keine Ausrutscher, sondern das, was nach oben geht, sind positive Ausrutscher. Und da frage ich mich halt tatsächlich, wie lange gucken sie sich das noch an? Jetzt sagen sie wieder, ne, mehr ist fest bei uns im Sattel. Weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube halt schon, dass du mit dem Kader ein bisschen mehr machen könntest. Aber jetzt natürlich keinen einstelligen Tabellenplatz. Aber ich finde es schon merkwürdig, dass da immer noch keine Reaktion gekommen ist.
Aber wenn ich mir so mal den Kader beim Kicker angucke, dann sehe ich, dass da fünf Mittelfeldspieler sind und zehn Stürmer. Das nenne ich einen unausgewogenen Kader. Und ich weiß jetzt nicht, wer da jetzt hauptverantwortlich ist, ob ich den Begovic sagen kann, ich will die Spieler, die Spieler, die Spieler oder ob das halt tatsächlich von Tobias Werner als Sportchef oder was auch immer er da ist, so verantwortlich ist.
Wobei, ich finde auch immer beim Kicker, manchmal nehmen die damit unter den Schwung.
Sie sind da manchmal etwas komisch, ja.
Ja, das ist manchmal so ein bisschen. Aber im Grunde, ja, hast du recht. Ich fand auch noch weitere Statistiken, die ich noch anmerken wollte. Wie gesagt, die Passquote dritt schlecht, das da haben wir schon. Drittmeiste Gegentore und die drittwenigsten Tore selbst geschossen. Das spricht auch alles dafür, dass das eher schlecht wird. Und Eva, du meinst, es wird langsam Zeit für einen Trainerwechsel da?
Ja, also ich meine, davon abgesehen, oder dass man drüber nachdenkt zumindest mal, muss man auch sagen, wer es soll kommen. Also, ich meine, wir sprechen gleich über einen der Trainer, der reinkommt, wo ich mich tatsächlich frage, das war der Trainer, den du in der Hinterhand hattest? Weiß ich jetzt nicht. Und es sind halt immer die gleichen Leute, die natürlich auch irgendwie immer genannt werden. Ich habe damals schon gesagt, als dann auch bei Daniel Scherning dann wieder die Kritik aufkam, wo ich mir so denke, ja, aber wer? Und die Hälfte sagt dann immer Bruno Labbadia, wo ich mir so denke, nicht ganz unser Preisregal, ich sage es, wie es ist, wäre nicht so das cleverste, davon habe ich gesehen, ob er zum Team passt. Das ist eine andere Frage. Aber es sind immer die gleichen fünf Namen in diesem Kreis. Als Erstes kommen immer Leute wie Florian Kohfeldt auf einmal wieder auf. Also irgendwelche Leute, die auch bei Bundesligavereinen nicht funktioniert haben, wo ich mir denke, ob die jetzt direkt in die zweite Liga gehen zu einem Abstiegskandidaten.
Ich finde aber auch gerade bei Abstiegskandidaten –Entschuldigung, wenn ich dich unterbreche –Ich finde gerade bei Abstiegskandidaten, egal welcher Liga, egal welcher Wettbewerb, finde ich das super, super schwierig zu sagen, wer tut sich das denn an quasi? Also in der Bundesliga der Frauen haben wir es zum Beispiel auch bei Turbine. Gut, da ist es eine ganz andere Geschichte nochmal, bei denen absolute Scheiße passiert. Entschuldigt bitte das Wort. Aber auch bei der Hertha, bei den Männern in der ersten Bundesliga, so Sachen, wo ich mich wirklich frage, wer tut sich das denn an? Und ich würde jetzt nicht unbedingt –verzeiht mir das bitte wirklich –ich würde Regensburg da auf keinen Fall mit Turbine und der Hertha irgendwie auf einen Nenner stellen. Aber es sieht ja wirklich schon nicht gut aus. Und dieser Abstiegskampf in der zweiten Liga, der ist wahnsinnig eng, wahnsinnig hart. Das ist unglaublich schwierig da, sich irgendwie zu behaupten. Und wenn dann eben immer nur fünf gleiche Namen dabei sind, ist es schwierig, davon einen zu wählen. Aber noch schwieriger, vielleicht auch wirklich jemanden neuen zu holen, der sich das auch antut oder so. Also ich weiß es auch nicht. Naja, Ena, der eben, also wenn wir das jetzt nochmal abbinden, genau, wie es weitergeht am Wochenende gegen Karlsruhe, in Karlsruhe auch. Das Hinspiel hatten sie ja 0 zu 6 verloren. Da ist noch eine Rechnung offen. Dann geht es gegen Düsseldorf und dann nach Kiel. Und jetzt kommen wir zu dem nächsten Trainer, der jetzt neu mit dabei ist, Sandhausen. Die haben auch Alois Schwarz entlassen und jetzt Thomas Oral eingestellt. Die sind ganz gut, also mit dem ersten, also das erste Spiel im neuen Jahr war ganz gut, 2 zu 1 gegen Arminia eben gewonnen danach, aber gegen Darmstadt verloren, gegen Düsseldorf verloren, gegen Karlsruhe verloren, jeweils kein Tor geschossen. Und dazwischen lag auch noch eine Niederlage gegen Freiburg im DFB-Pokal, 0 zu 2. Und ich hab das Spiel getickert, es war so grauenvoll. Es war wirklich so ein grausames Spiel, sich das über 90 Minuten anzugucken, da ging quasi was gar nichts. Aber wie gesagt, seit vier Spielen wartet man auf ein eigenes Tor und auch logischerweise dann auf einen Sieg. Die Tamsen, Thomas Oral. Eva, du hast bei Twitter geschrieben, dass du das schon angekündigt hast, bevor die Pressemitteilung raus war. Oral war Co-Trainer unter Felix Maggert in Fulheim 2013-14, war auch beim FSV Frankfurt da auch sportlicher Leiter, war dann beim KSC bei Ingolstadt, wo er im Juni 2021 hier gegangen ist, war auch 2010-11 in Leipzig, als die noch Regionalliga gespielt haben. Also da auch so ein bisschen was von der Rabaschule mit abgegriffen. Eva, was erwartest du denn jetzt von Oral?
Ja, also man muss dazu sagen, das ist genau das, was ich meine. Man hat irgendwie über Nachfolger, wie als Bielefelder sagen, ich frage Kramer, Uli Forte, nimm die mal alle von unserem Ding. Und ich habe dann auch Spaß gehabt, ja, Thomas Oral gibt es ja auch noch, weil das ja immer der Klassikamoo von Ingolstadt irgendwann war. Ja, hier, wer immer auch gerade Trainer ist, der fliegt jetzt und wir holen Oral und dann in eine Relegation. Dann haben die halt den tatsächlich geholt. Und was, also wirklich, wenn ich als allererstes auf Ingolstadt gucke und auf das System, was Oral mit Ingolstadt gespielt hat, das war hauptsächlich ein 4-4-2. So, Sandhausen spielt eigentlich vor allem mit einer einsamen Spitze, wo ich auch sagen muss, da hat man jetzt Al-Gadoui geholt. Ich verstehe nicht, wer eine Doppelspitze bei Sandhausen stellen sollte, Nummer eins, davon eh abgesehen, dass sich ein Fokus absolut ins Mittelfeld und ins offensive Mittelfeld mit den Kids-Zombie-Brüdern legen würde, auch mit Spielern mit Aydini, mit Esfain. Ich sehe aber keine Doppelspitze bei Sandhausen. Ich sehe, dass man vor allem über das spielerische, es ist halt ein bisschen schwierig, also ohne da gemeint zu sein, aber es ist halt schwierig, da komplett auf spielerische zu gehen, aber durch spielerische im Mittelfeld zu gehen, dass es das für sich gut bespielen kann. Und ich weiß nicht, ob Oral, der auch bei Ingolstadt natürlich immer mit Spielern wie Kutke gearbeitet hat, ob das wirklich so der Weg ist. Ich weiß es nicht. Und gerade defensiv ist es halt auch wirklich nicht ansehnlich, was Sandhausen da zustande bringt. Die haben auch immer wieder viel mit Problemen, von Verletzungen zu kämpfen. Das ist auch wirklich nicht schön gewesen. Ich glaube, zwischendurch fünf Torhüter unter Vertrag, weil die ersten drei dann irgendwann verletzt waren. Dann hat man neun geholt, der hat sich dann auch direkt verletzt. Das spielt auch noch alles mit rein. Aber selbst absolute Leistungsträger in der Defensive wie einen Schirov, die mit defensiven Fehlern gegen Karlsruhe auftauchen, würde ich mir denken, okay. Gleichzeitig genau gleiches Spiel wie Nürnberg. Warum jetzt der Trainerwechsel? Was sollte Alui Schwarz in diesen ersten vier Spielen machen? Außer gegen Bielefeld gewinnen. We had this, it's not a big deal. So passiert vielen Vereinen in dieser Liga. Dann hattest du Darmstadt. Sorry, da erwartet ja sowieso niemand, dass du das gewinnst. Okay, wie du es verlierst, ist halt noch eine Sache. Das Düsseldorf-Spiel, gut, da hast du offensiv einfach nichts angeboten. Düsseldorf hat es dann irgendwann gemacht. Und dann Karlsruhe. Und jetzt hast du das Spiel gegen Nürnberg, wo du ganz genau weißt, dass du eigentlich gewinnen musst. Und dann holst du Thomas Oral. Mir fehlt da einfach ein bisschen die Fantasie. Wir haben über Kontinuität, wie wichtig es ist, dass Trainer in Transferphasen mit eingebunden werden. Du hattest jetzt die Möglichkeit, mit einer 2-monatigen Pause da irgendwas dran zu ändern. Und du hattest so einen Nee. Also, der hat jetzt zwar ein Spiel gewonnen. Also, das war es jetzt.
Das muss ich auch sagen, das ist wirklich merkwürdig. Sie haben ja in der Winterpause auch noch nachgelegt mit Fraunberger und Chadanoglu für die offensiven Außenverteidiger. Und da dachte ich mir auch so, okay, du nimmst quasi Diegmeier raus, ein Okorotschi raus, dafür holst du die zwei und setzt es erstmal ein. Dann hast du da jetzt eine Stellschraube gedreht, die sich mir nicht zwingend aufgetan hat. Dann holst du Al-Ghadaoui, Evina und noch den Bruder von unserem Melem. Und jetzt entlässt du einen Trainer. Das ist irgendwie merkwürdig. Und ich habe auch beim Kicker über eine Zahl gestolpert, in der aktuellen Ausgabe, dass die in den letzten 11 Spielzeiten 158 Spieler verpflichtet haben. Das ist ja unfassbar. So ein bisschen Kontinuität schreibt sich, glaube ich, anders. Und neue Bezen kehren gut, wenn es auf dem Spielfeld ist. Oftmals hat es irgendwie geklappt, aber jetzt hinterlässt es mich doch sehr ratlos. Und gerade dieses Spiel gegen Darmstadt, das war für uns im Vorfeld im Podcast keinesfalls ausgemacht, dass wir da gewinnen. Weil wir wussten, gegen Bielefeld sind sie erst mal gut aus der Winterpause gekommen. Gegen Sandhausen kann man sich schon mal schwer tun, vor allem, wenn man sich an das Hinspiel erinnert hat. Da war mit Buchtmann und den Kindzombies einfach eine Körperlichkeit auf dem Platz, die schon wirklich à la bonheur sein kann. Und dann spielen wir da. Erster Standard, Kopfball-Tor. Kopfball durch Honsack, der ja auch erst frisch aus einer langen Verletzung kommt. Erster Startelf-Einsatz. Der macht danach noch gleich das 2-0, was von Tietz vorbereitet war, aber auch Haarsträuben in der Verteidigung. Und das Spiel war auch Deckel drauf. Und dann machen sie noch das 3-0 und das 4-0. Und so hätte ich Sandhausen nicht mir vorgestellt, dass die so das Spiel hinten runterkippen lassen. Und deshalb war für mich das im Vorfeld überhaupt nicht ausgemacht. Und dann, oh, das war ein leichter 3er. Also das war ja echt erstaunlich. Und das Stadion war auch so, Hälfte da am Start, Hälfte Sandhausen. Und da kam halt auch kein Impuls von Rängen. Also das ist eher so ein Publikum, da gibt es die Ultras hinter dem Block, aber dann ist es doch eher so ein bisschen, mal gucken, was geht. Und das sind jetzt keine guten Moves, die sich da jetzt oder Vibes bei mir auftun.
Nee, also vor allem das Ding ist ja gerade, weil Alois Schwarz auch damals für Koschinat geholt wurde, für die stabile Defensive. Und davon ist diese Saison für mich nicht übrig geblieben. Also sie haben zweimal gegen Bielefeld gewonnen, aber zweimal auch in einer Art und Weise, wo man wieder sagen muss, lag mehr am Gegner als an Sandhausen an sich. So da wieder ein Kind-Zombie-Moment. Es liegt definitiv dann nicht am Torhüter. Patrick Devis gehört für mich zu einem der besseren Torhüter der Liga. Es ist unfassbar unglücklich, dass er auch so verletzt war. Aber du hast auch mit Bachmann, was du angesprochen hast, einen Spieler, wo man drauf schauen kann. Aber sie haben halt auch einfach super viele Abgänge. Alleine letzte Saison hatten sie, glaube ich, zehn Winterabgänge und Neuzugänge. Also so etwas, wo andere Vereine sagen, ja, dann justieren wir mal ganz leicht nach. Ich meine, was sie bis jetzt nicht verkraftet haben, ist der erste Abgang von Pascal Testroth, der ja zur Ingolstadt gegangen ist. Dann hatte man Pull Krabb geholt, der diese Rolle überhaupt nicht füllen kann. Bei Al-Gadoui, ich denke mir halt, wenn ich dann irgendwann rausbekommen habe in der Saison, wir brauchen gar nicht diesen klassischen Stoßstürmer vorne drin, weil über die Standardstärke mit einem Okurochi kann ich auch einen Schirov und einen Bachmann darstellen. Und dann versuche ich aber auf Teufel, komme raus, wieder so einen Testroth reinzubringen mäßig und hole Al-Gadoui, gegen den ich persönlich nichts habe. Ich meine, der hat bei Stuttgart auch –also ich glaube, er ist ein ganz guter Zweitliga-Stürmer.
Er ist halt aber auch schon 32, ne?
Ja, und nochmal, eigentlich hast du ja was gefunden. Also du kannst eigentlich über die Außen –auch ich fand Gianna Lunu jetzt auch nicht schlecht. Ich finde auch einen Framberger, der kann sich gut auf der Seite durchsetzen. Aber ich glaube, diese Mannschaft weiß überhaupt nicht, was sie anstellen soll, wenn sie in den Strafraum kommt, weil die so oft den Fokus geschiftet haben diese Saison, wo ich mich frage, aber wer soll da denn auch stehen? Also es ist vollkommen egal, wer steht, weil irgendwie ist es auch überhaupt nicht klar, machen wir es jetzt über das Mittelfeld, machen wir es jetzt über die Außen. Es ist irgendwie ein Überangebot da, dafür, dass es keine Nachfrage für diese Bälle gibt.
Also auch da ein sehr großes Fragezeichen, wie das funktionieren soll, ne?
Ja, also du hast den Pulgrab, glaube ich, heißt er noch, der Tscheche, der hatte am zweiten Spieltag in Namtstadt auch seine erste Auswärtsfahrt in der zweiten Liga. Und der war für mich eher ein Leichtgewicht. Also der war deutlich abfallend von der Leistung. Und da dachte ich mir nachher noch so, da wird sie schon noch dran gewöhnen müssen, um Faktor zu sein, der im Moment gar nicht ist. Und so ähnlich war es bei uns in Namtstadt mit Warming und Wilhelmsson, zwei junge Skandinavier, die auch an Körperlichkeit noch zulegen müssen. Und die sind deutlich junger als Pulgrab. Also irgendwie dachte ich mir auch, ob der Transfer aufgeht und, naja, scheint sich so ein bisschen einzureihen in ein paar fragwürdigere Transfers.
Tanja, fällt dir noch was ein zu Sandhausen?
Ich finde es eigentlich sehr faszinierend, dass man mit dem Blick aus der ersten Liga, zum Beispiel, nennt man ja immer Sandhausen und Heidenheim in einem Atemzug sozusagen. Aber eigentlich sind das zwei völlig völlige Gegensätze. Weil du hast bei Heidenheim diese absolute Kontinuität, diesen absoluten Plan, wie sie spielen wollen und wie sie ihre Mannschaft zusammenstellen und mit Frank Schmidt diesen absoluten Anker. Während bei Sandhausen geht es wirklich kurvenweise auf und ab. Und mal haben sie wieder eine bisschen bessere Saison, wo sie auch mal ein bisschen oben mit anklopfen können. Aber dann geht es auch wieder gnadenlos runter in den Keller, wo sie dann wieder gegen den Abstieg spielen. Weil sie da auch diese Kontinuität, die du in der 2. Liga brauchst, nicht reinkriegen.
Machen wir mal einen Deckel drauf. Für Sandhausen geht es weiter am Wochenende gegen Nürnberg. Eben auch nach der Trainerentlassung, wie wir das ja schon gesagt hatten. Dann geht es gegen Kiel und dann gegen Lautern. Also alles nicht so einfache Partien. Und damit würde ich sagen, sind wir durch, oder? Habt ihr noch irgendwas, was euch auf dem Herzen liegt, was ihr unbedingt noch mitteilen wollt?
Vielleicht noch ein Fun-Fact zu Thorsten Lieberknecht bei den Ligien. Er ist jetzt seit insgesamt 55 Zweitligaspielen am Böllenfalltor. Ihr dürft mal raten, wie viele Punkte er da wohl ergattert, seither in 55 Spielen in der zweiten Liga. Ja, also es geht um die Punkte.
Okay, das würde nicht passen.
108 Punkte in 55 Zweitligaspielen, das bedeutet, 2-Punkte-Schnitt. Sorry, wenn ich hier gerade jemanden mit meiner Frage verwirrt habe. Also es ging um die Punkte in der zweiten Liga in 55 Spielen. 108 Punkte, das ist wirklich eine lange Distanz, ein 2er Schnitt. Und das ist schon krass, positiv krass.
Ich dachte, du willst jetzt so auf die 55-55-mäßig Prass zum Jubiläum.
Ja, aber das hätte auch irgendwie nicht gepasst. Wenn man länger drüber dachte, das wäre sehr wenig gewesen. Also wer drinnen im Abschließkart?
Wir haben letztes Jahr 7 Punkte geholt und davor haben wir einfach noch ein paar geschenkt bekommen.
Es ist ein 2-Stunden-Kurzpass.
Eben ein langen Pass quasi. Sorry dafür. Aber es hat mir sehr, sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Danke in die Runde. Ganz lieben Dank an euch fürs Zuhören und an euch fürs Dabeisein, an Eva-Lotta Bohle vom 2. Bundesliga-Podcast at Eva-Bohle auf Twitter, an Matthias Kneifl, Buchautor, Blogger, Podcaster, beim Ligien-Podcast Hoch und Weit, außerdem gelernter Historiker, auf Twitter zu finden, als Kick-Schuh-Blog. Und ganz lieben Dank auch an Tanja Hufschmidt vom HSV-Talk, manchmal auch bei frvzuhören.fschmidt77 auf Twitter. Schön, dass ihr alle dabei wart. Ganz lieben Dank.
Danke für die Einladung.
Danke dir für die Moderation.
Ja, ganz lieben Dank auf jeden Fall. Und auf ein gutes Topspiel am Samstagabend, würde ich mal sagen. Möge der bessere, möge das bessere Team gewinnen. Und an euch, Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Danke, dass ihr auch immer so lieb seid und mich auch so gut aufnehmt. Nächste Woche hört ihr wieder Max in der Schlusskonferenz mindestens. Und wenn ihr mehr von mir und zum Fußball der Frauen vielleicht auch hören wollt, ich meine, da gibt es natürlich auch immer Kurzpässe von Max dazu, die auch immer sehr, sehr höhrenswert sind, kann ich nur sehr empfehlen. Ich mache aber auch eben den Podcast die 45. Da spreche ich jede Woche mit Spielerinnen, aber eben auch mit so tollen Personen wie einer Tuber-Tackerl, die mit ihren Scoring Girls wirklich ganz, ganz tolle Dinge macht. Hört da sehr gerne mal rein. Und insgesamt kann ich auch noch sehr ans Herz legen, die Bundesliga der Frauen, auf jeden Fall sehens- und verfolgenswert. Ansonsten auch nochmal der Hinweis sehr gerne, registriert euch im supportersclub.rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Denkt dran, die Überweisungen anzupassen. Der Rasenfunk ist jetzt eine GmbH. Und lest unbedingt Maxbuch, falls ihr das noch nicht getan habt. Ansonsten tschüssi, ciao ciao, bis zum nächsten Mal.